Hey everybody, welcome to the podcast.
You guys are in for a treat today
because my guest is Caroline Burckle.
Caroline is a 2012 Olympian.
She's a 23 time all American swimmer
an NCAA champion and NCAA a record holder.
One of my very favorite people,
I absolutely adore her.
This is an amazing and powerful conversation.
So hit that subscribe button
and please enjoy my conversation with Caroline Burckle.
All right, we're rolling Burckle
you're in the house.
Hey, dude.
It took a minute to make this happen.
I know.
I think for a reason.
Yeah.
(indistinct)
Definitely for a reason.
Well, we met.
Was it like five years ago at this point
at that Mind, Body green thing?
Dude, I saw that picture the other day,
it popped up in my reminders.
Oh memories thing, yeah.
Memories.
What years was that?
It might have been 2015,
We tool it--
2016 maybe?
To send a Jack.
Right.
And it was, I remember specifically,
I was like, dude, we know, I know, the same person you know,
And it was like this moment where we,
let's send him a selfie.
Well, it wasn't,
it wasn't the kind of conference
where you expect to run into swimmers?
Yeah, no.
Yeah.
So I didn't know who you were.
And then we met, we immediately hit it off.
That was super fun to establish
that we both were friends with Jack Roche,
who's this beautiful mentor in the swimming community.
This amazing human being who I know means so much to you,
and is a more recent friend of mine,
but somebody who I care deeply about.
So that was like our meeting point on Me Cute.
And then we became friends ever since.
And I think the last time I saw you was that in,
up in Tahoe when we did that training camp?
Yes.
So it's been a couple years, that was 2017.
Yeah, there's a reason for that on my end but--
And here's the thing, the minute I met you,
I was like, this girl is lit,
like she would be great for the podcast
but she's dealing with a few things
I think I'll let her bake for a little while.
Yeah you needed
to let me bake.
Sort a few things out.
And I'm glad that I did.
Like you said these things, that timing is important.
And I think the time for this is perfect right now.
I think had we done it a couple years earlier,
it would be a very different conversation.
Very different, half of the things
I would have never been aware of half of the things
that I would wanna talk about.
It wouldn't even have been in my consciousness,
like it would have been buried seven layers deep.
Laid out.
Maybe I could have teased it out a little bit, bout--
Yeah, I would have been like sobbing my eyes.
But now you're fully embracing this growth trajectory
that you've been on and I think what's unique
and interesting about you,
as somebody who has hosted several conversations
with Olympians over the years,
and plenty of Olympic swimmers,
most of those conversations are rooted
in the Olympic experience itself,
and we're gonna talk about that with you, of course.
But what's most interesting about your story
is the aftermath of that,
and the kind of growth that you've experienced
and the issues that you've wrestled with,
post career to become this more actualized human being.
Yeah, it's been a ride.
When I think back,
I was actually listening to your podcast with john Moffitt.
Sunday morning?
Oh, my God.
I was walking, I was on my power walk for five, six miles,
'cause I'm trying to get some foot time in right now,
trying to get back to running still.
Still in this five year journey back to running.
And I was listening to that podcast with him
and it was just speaking to me,
'cause he was like, I don't even remember that person.
I don't even remember the person that competed in the games,
I remember this other person that was,
afterward and the feelings that I had
and the emotions that went
through this process to transition.
And I felt so seen, I was like, I feel seen
I'm not the only person that feels like,
I just don't identify with that one Olympic name in my life.
That wasn't just it for me.
And I feel selfish.
I feel selfish, saying that.
Why?
Admittedly right now,
I feel selfish thing.
Because you feel like it's such a gift
to have had that Olympic experience.
And with that, there's some responsibility
that you shoulder to communicate about it in a certain way?
Yeah, because here I am 34,
I run a business of Olympic and professional athletes
that give back to the next generation,
and I have shame associated with being an Olympian.
So it's like this poll of both directions.
It's like, you need to be this
and you need to be really proud of it.
But you also like had this experience with it,
and you're not really wanting to claim
and own some of that experience.
And so how can you settle in the middle of that?
But what is that about?
Like, where does the shame emanate from?
Where do you wanna start?
Let's start at the beginning,
we can go all the way back to the beginning.
We can go back to the quarry pool in Kentucky.
Oh man, did you ever swim there?
I haven't, but it's on my bucket list.
I love outdoor pools like that,
I was in Austin a few weeks ago.
And--
I saw you there.
(indistinct) Springs and I just, you know,
and when I was in Australia,
swimming it icebergs every day like I love those pools.
I was jealous when you were there.
To answer to sort of, say the first thing first
about the shame with being an Olympian
and the shame, why is it that it's so difficult
to say that you have that if you're also trying
to hold this image that you're proud of it?
Is that I have this concept in my mind
that I cannot have both.
I cannot have a feeling about being an Olympian
that's negative and also the feeling
about being an Olympian that's positive.
I've been raised to think--
So you default to the negative?
Yeah, I'm sure you very well know that.
I know you well,
I feel like I get you
Not being an Olympian,
I can't own that aspect of it.
But the feeling of,
how could I be so proud of it
and also have so much trauma
and shame associated with the same thing?
Like, how are both of those things possible?
And I grew up, growing up,
I didn't think I could have two feelings.
You had to have one feeling
and it needs to be this and you need to follow that.
Like, you're not allowed to have multiple opinions
and feelings and--
Or perhaps the shame is a result of not feeling the way
that you feel like you're supposed to feel
about that experience.
Right, yeah.
'Cause that's what isn't been ingrained.
Is that that is just that's it.
You've gotta feel really good about that.
Do you know how lucky you are?
Okay, so shall we start there?
Because that is something I've been unpacking a lot
over the past couple years.
Is, growing up, I grew up in this amazing pool,
this great city, this wonderful family,
it was it was wonderful.
But the society that I grew up in Louisville
was very much, you should be very grateful
for what you have, don't question it
this is the way it is, this is who you are.
And I and I grew up in this mindset of,
well, I have it, I can't have a darn bad feeling
to save my life, 'cause if I have a bad feeling,
or if I have a negative feeling
or thought or emotion that comes up,
then I'm a bad person, my character is bad.
Does that come from the parents?
The parental units?
Or where does that idea germinate from?
It comes from several avenues.
I grew up in a very strict Catholic school system.
So go church three times a week,
oh, my goodness,
I mean, so church three times a week, and it,
I don't wanna talk poorly about the the system that it was,
but I always felt like I was so different
than everybody there, in the first place.
So I grew up in this place
where everyone's telling me what to do and how to do it
and I didn't like that.
I didn't like that feeling of,
why do I have to think one way?
So it originated there, this I have to please.
I can't have my own thoughts and opinions and emotions.
I can't have more than one feeling
and it needs to be positive,
or else people will be upset with me.
And so that whole thing that I've been unpacking
was sort of a pattern that I continue
to follow throughout my career in my life.
Your brother doesn't seem to harbor that though.
Interestingly enough, not as much.
Yeah, so part of that, perhaps,
is because you were a girl.
My father was tough.
So your parents were both athletes.
Your dad owned all these like fitness clubs, right?
Tennis and swim class?
Tennis and swim class.
So it was a very
active ensemble.
Yeah, so he swam for UVO, he's known for Lakeside.
He was like married to his teammate.
And him and Mary T grew up together
she would kick his ass the whole thing.
So Mary T is gotta be like,
a huge looming presence and in the swimming kind
of lore of Kentucky, right?
She's amazing.
For people that don't know I mean,
she dominated butterfly for years and set world records
that at the time just seemed untouchable.
Oh, my God, Madame Butterfly.
I mean, her stories, the stories just of her practice,
with her lungs collapsing
and her finishing 10 five hundreds butterfly.
It's insane.
I'm like, wait, your your lungs collapsed
and you finished 10 500 butterfly, like,
what are you talking about?
So, she was a legend there.
And it was a gift just to swim for Lakeside,
it was like, you're lucky you're in this space
where you're in this outdoor rock quarry pool.
You should be so lucky.
And, so yeah, so my dad owns these fitness clubs
my mom is a tennis player.
So she played professional top Pro.
And her whole mindset is she's from here,
she's from California.
So she's just like, whew, like,
you do you, I'ma do me.
Her whole deal is very open mind free mind,
she's just very spirited,
and my dad is very strict,
and, dogmatic and follows the rules.
And so the combo of them,
I think, was confusing for me as a child.
'Cause I felt this pull to like, please.
But then also you can do whatever you want,
do what you want.
Please, you can do whatever you want
and be whoever you want.
And--
But a little bit of each of those is probably good.
Absolutely.
And they also, grew up in really
tough environments themselves.
So like, knowing where they came from,
and what their background is,
makes a whole lot of sense.
So that's sort of where all this originated.
Is in this space of as a child,
how can how could I have had more than one feeling?
And not only plea I had to please.
But that came from everywhere.
Well, the people pleasing comes
into play in a big way later down the line,
we're gonna work our way up to that.
But at this early age,
was there an expectation,
like, you're gonna be this athlete,
or it was just us kind of the atmosphere
that you were in, right?
It was just an active environment.
And you were just by dint of being your parents kid,
like around a swimming pool all the time.
Yeah, so they dropped us off at 08:00 a.m
pick us up at 09:00 p.m when it closed.
We were at the pool all day long.
I mean, not totally unsupervised
just running around like pool rats,
Clark was competing with every 18 year old
as a nine year old, he's like, let's compete,
let's do this.
I was not that way, really, I had a very
more of a calm demeanor with competition.
I wasn't really like a savage competitor,
didn't really have this, like,
I'm gonna do this and win.
And like, I need to train, 20 hours a day.
And but I had this, I wanna be around my friends.
I enjoy the social aspect of it
and I really liked this feeling
of being a part of a team and a community
and my suits cute,
and all of these different things that I could experience
as a young girl that felt like
I was just free to be me in that space.
I could just be me.
That's so interesting,
because that's a typical,
somebody who excels at the highest level, right?
Like you're have this kind of freewheeling approach
to the whole thing.
Was the talent immediately evident from the beginning?
Or did that how did you grow into that aspect
of being a true competitor?
I had a lot of talent, as a young girl,
I had a lot of natural, just fluid talent.
I was not a workhorse, I was a racehorse
so I didn't perform in practice.
So when people would see me as a little girl,
they would have never guessed that I was really good,
'cause I was dog last in practice all the time.
But then you get up on the blocks
on the race and win.
Yeah, I had something innate within me
that I could click on and off very well.
I didn't have to show that approve that to people,
I didn't feel the need to do that.
Swimming felt like this artistic expression
or something internal that I could do
that felt for one time, in my day,
or in my life, or in my week, I could feel free
and that I didn't have to do it for anybody else.
That's a very 2020 relationship to sport,
but not a very 1995 relationship to sport.
But that's why I felt so outcast
with, nobody understood me.
There wasn't a Meet that went by
as a child, in high school and college,
to where I really felt seen
for how I performed and the way that I trained
and the way that I saw my relationship with the sport.
I wasn't obsessed with times,
I wasn't obsessed with stats,
I didn't know any of that.
My brother was that.
My brother was like, boom, boom, boom, time.
Here's your split,
but I'm like, I can't.
I'm trying to visualize what the communication
would have been like with your coaches at the time then
'cause that must have been frustrating.
Very.
Or was it a situation
in which they're they're trying to jam
this square peg into a round hole
and you're just doing your own thing?
Yeah, Mike De Boer.
Do you know Mike?
Legend--
Likes
(indistinct)
Legend of a coach.
He got me.
It took him a little bit, but he got me.
And so once I got into his group,
so it's like, bronze, silver gold,
pretty senior senior.
Once I got into his senior group,
it was like, boom,
I could feel seen I was,
which I know, it's a very cliche term,
but now looking back,
I felt so comfortable with him
because he understood the way that I performed
was in my body, it was a somatic experience of this feeling.
I was a feeling athlete, and I wasn't a thinking athlete
and have the stats and the splits and all that down.
I had no idea.
No idea what I was going into at a Meet,
I had no idea what ranking I was,
I had no idea, I'd miss my races all the time.
'Cause I didn't pay attention.
Kind of hilarious and endearing, though,
because swimming is so stats driven,
it's all about, what the pace clock is telling you
and your heart rate
even though kind of the splits that you need to hit
to get your goal time.
And what the Olympic Trials qualifying time is,
and all of that stuff is like,
imprinted onto the brain.
But not for you.
And I tried, I tried really hard.
I remember sitting down and writing my goals and trying
to figure out my splits.
And I remember these stories
where I would sit at the kitchen table
at our very first house, Barbary Lane.
And my parents would sit there and help me,
my mom, of course, had no she was not into that either
but my dad would sit and help me with splits.
And I just did not understand it.
There was no comprehension at all,
as a child like I, it was right over my head.
And I tried, I tried really hard.
And I'm glad that I did
'cause I could see that side of it
that's really important to develop and understand.
But I personally just, it didn't resonate with me.
So I suspect not so good in math class.
Horrible.
Failed all the way through.
But like, oddly enough, like,
all A's and language arts and art and spelling
and science and social studies and all these other classes,
but math straight fail.
And I would go to tutors and I, I come home crying so much,
just 'cause I felt like I was a failure.
'Cause I wasn't the same as everybody else.
My school was a math and science school.
It was heavy in that and I was this artist,
this mind that was free thinking
and saw things abstractly,
and, shapes and all and all these things.
I count things by, like this curtain right here,
I'll count by the number of creases in it, like, I'm weird,
I think of things in a very odd and abstract way
and that was not okay.
When I, that was not okay,
that was very confusing to people.
And so once I started to realize that,
I started to gear myself more towards things like that
in high school and stuff,
I took art and AP art and stayed in that lane.
But when it came to swimming,
I really had to work with Mike
on what that looked like for me,
because I wasn't the same as everybody else in the pool.
Interesting.
Do you think that your swimming career
would have looked different
if you just stayed under his tutelage the whole time?
Oh, yeah.
'Cause he understood you.
I think there would have been a learning curve
again, and again, and again,
as I went on through the ranks of it.
I would have changed and I would have grown
and I would have gone through XYZ,
and it would have gone over again.
But I think about that all the time,
just like what I could have achieved,
or done differently.
And I suppose that's normal for people to think about.
Sure.
But yeah, having to go to college then
and sort of relearn, or have a coach relearn me
was the whole exhaustion, exhausting process.
We're getting up to that.
But first was there,
I'm wondering whether there was like an inflection point
early in your career when you were still in high school
where you were like, oh, man, I'm really good at this.
Was there a race or an event
or something that occurred that dawned upon you
like, I've got a real bright future?
Yes, so I was a breast stroker first.
That's weird, I wouldn't have thought that.
I mean, it was my first Junior National Cut
and my first Senior National Cut.
So how old were you when you first made Junior Nationals?
13.
Yeah, okay.
I didn't go.
Why not?
'Cause I wasn't ready.
According to who.
Me, so I had this--
Who doesn't go?
And that's a big deal
I know.
You make that that qualifying time.
I remember so it was at the University of Kentucky
I made it in 100 breaststroke,
and I got out and I remember my brother was like,
pumping his chest just like happier than I was.
I was like, sick, I made this cut.
Like, I don't even care.
it was this weird thing.
He's like, "Dude, do you know what that means?"
"Do you know what that means,
"you get to go to this Meets in Orlando."
And all this stuff.
And I'm like, no, I'm not going, I start crying on deck.
And Mike looked at me and he is like,
I could cry right now
and, me, I'm very vulnerable and emotional.
So thanks for bearing with me.
But he, he looked at me and he goes,
"You don't you don't wanna go?"
And I said, "No, I'm not ready for that yet.
"I'm not there yet."
And he was like, "Okay."
That's a impressive level of self awareness.
For a young person, though.
I was extremely self aware.
I don't.
But how much of that was just fear of the unknown
verses self understanding.
Certainly fear 100% fear.
But my fear was stemming from going there
and not making people happy if I performed poorly.
So my fear was never that I wouldn't do well,
'cause my fear didn't,
how do I say this?
Like, without sounding weird.
I had a really strong trust in my ability.
I knew I wasn't gonna be a bad swimmer.
My fear was that I wouldn't please people.
My fear was that I go, and I'd fail,
and people would be upset with me.
And if they're upset with me,
that means I'm a bad person,
and then if I'm a bad person, that means,
whatever else it means.
But it doesn't sound like your parents cared that much,
so it wasn't coming from them was it?
That's the crazy thing,
'cause they were extremely hands off with my swimming.
My mom didn't even know what
like, I'd swim and she would say,
"Oh, my God, that was, it was a great swim."
Mom, I just added 10 seconds,
she had no, she was just you,
but you were the cutest one out there.
I'm like, "Thanks, Mom."
My dad was more in tuned.
But they never made me feel badly
for any of my performances.
So I've started to realize that I was running
from something throughout this time,
and then I kept running, which we'll get to,
but I was running from something
and I think I just have this
and I had this very strong fear of upsetting people
and I still think, I think if you ask anybody that,
where does that come from?
Sure, you can pinpoint a person
or a place or a thing or whatever,
but truthfully, you create a story
about where that comes from.
You create what that looks like
and then you've had this whole scenario
in your head about why you're not pleasing people.
And I was so imaginative that my stories
were seven ceilings high.
To me, it almost sounds like,
fear of your own strength and power.
That if you were to go to a Meet like that,
and actually excel at the level
that innately you knew you were capable of,
that that would actually be the thing
that would upset people.
Not failing, but actually being as awesome as you knew
that you could be, that might ruffle feathers,
does that fit?
Yeah, you struck a chord just there, for sure.
because upsetting people to me was not being liked, right?
So if I'm not liked,
which is the same thing as what you're saying,
if I beat other girls, if I do great.
What does that mean?
They don't like me.
And if I'm not liked by these girls,
or by these people, then I'm a bad person.
It all stems back to this, like innate worthiness
within myself that I'm just not a good person
if that happens.
Which is so interesting,
how that manifested at such a young age.
But I, this happened all the time,
I would let people beat me.
I would literally let people beat me in Meet sometimes
because I was afraid to win.
I'd be looking around and they would be passing me
and I would be like, relieved.
It was crazy.
And really, and then I get to the wall and just be so upset,
'cause I knew that I could have won
and I still have my best races in my life
I knew I could have gone seven seconds fast on that.
It was more important to you to fit in
than it was to excel at the level you were capable of.
Yeah.
And it's, it's a very,
it's an intense emotion to revisit.
'Cause, then you think well, what could I have done?
How do you train somebody to not give a shit
about what people think?
How do you catch this?
and you could go down the rabbit hole
of all the ways I could have done it differently.
But the truth of the matter is, as a young woman,
I didn't feel worthy enough.
And bottom line, the issue was I didn't feel worthy enough.
And so that, as a woman, and as a young girl,
I would imagine so many people feel the same way
and I know for a fact.
Everyone is human.
That's the thing.
I mean, some people, maybe the majority
of people listening to this might struggle
to connect with or relate to,
the high highs of your career
and going to the Olympics and all of that,
but that experience that you just related,
I think is highly relatable,
especially particularly to young female athletes.
Or young females in general,
'cause I don't think it's a thing
that many guys go through.
But you can see it with young girls all over the place.
All over the place, and there's nothing wrong with it,
I think it's just we're catching it faster.
like, we're able to catch it faster,
people are becoming more aware,
coaches can become more aware, parents, friends, peers
can become more aware when someone's like,
I'm not good enough.
I don't want this person to be mad at me.
That's being caught faster, I think
so that these young women
can actually move up a little a little better
and a little stronger and a little more empowered.
And, I say all this and it's,
I'm so human, like,
I don't have a problem with saying,
I knew that I was amazing and also freaked out
that people wouldn't like me.
But yeah, that's so real.
That idea of I'm not good enough,
but also the idea of it's not okay to be too good.
Yeah, too much.
And you still stumble forward,
and continue to excel as you mature as an athlete.
Yeah, it's--
So, that must have been
a little war that you're waging
in your consciousness?
Yeah, it's a trip to think back to when you're young
and to start unpacking.
I don't know, if you've ever done stuff like this,
where you just go back and it's not just the past 10 years,
but it's the 10 before that, and then you start
to realize--
Trust me.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure you have,
just gonna throw out there.
But, it's so fascinating to see the patterns,
and the different things
that you thought were just this problem,
and you need to push down
and when you can finally just say it, and be like,
I was afraid of being too much.
And I was not, I didn't think I was enough.
And just say it right, and like,
get it off your body and let it out of your system.
Its like, whoa, okay I feel better now,
now, where do I start?
Right, and it's confusing--
One year.
'cause those two ideas seem at odds with each other.
How can you possibly harbor
both of those thoughts at the same time?
It goes back to the two thoughts part, right?
I can't have both of those.
So it just must be one.
And I just need to stick with it and deal with it
and shove it down and move on
and keep competing and make everybody happy
and then it's like, whatever.
And that was my mindset, is just like,
well just keep going.
Yeah the alcoholic disposition is,
you feel like, you're superior to everybody
and more than anybody else,
and you're more capable than anyone else.
And at the same time, you're a complete piece of shit,
and you don't deserve anything.
And those two identities coexisting at the same time.
Neither of which are true.
Right, and we create these stories
that becomes such a reality.
And especially if you're an imaginative soul,
and you have all these, little fairy thing in mind.
(indistinct) Autistic sensibility Caroline.
Nothing is in like a linear sequence in your brain.
You've got like, 12 different Alison Wonderlands going on,
So it's like, Oh, that must be true.
Oh, that must be true.
Well, that's true.
And you're picking from all these parts of yourself.
And I think that's where I could, that was a blessing,
but it could also be a curse,
for me as a swimmer and as a human in general.
But it was it, it was a lot to unpack when I finally did,
there's a lot of shame that comes with that.
'cause you feel, I think what I started
to really pick apart I guess I don't know
if that's the right word, but dissect,
was how is it possible
to hold space for something like that?
Like how is it possible to hold space for
parts of you that you have a lot of shame in,
parts of you that you have a lot of grief
you grief parts of yourself and people pleasing,
which is weird thing as well.
And also not sound like a victim
all the time or like you're complaining?
so doing that works hard,
'cause you don't know how to say it
and feel like you can own it and claim it,
'cause you don't wanna complain.
You don't wanna sound like you're complaining to people.
You don't want to be a burden to other people too,
with that.
So I just didn't,
and I just didn't for however long and it manifested
How did that work out?
Horribly.
All right.
So by the time you're a senior in high school, though,
you're crushing it, I assume you're getting recruited
at all these colleges,
you're probably rocking out the energy,
records and all that kind of stuff at that point.
Yeah, so my college recruiting experience
was really interesting.
I went to Arizona, Texas, Northwestern Florida,
Cal and Stanford, Stanford.
My mom was like, let's go to California.
My dad's like no.
So I ended up having to choose between Arizona
and Florida 'cause I want to train with the guys.
I love training
with the guys.
Those were the only
two programs where they train together?
Yeah.
I end up choosing--
So, what was that about?
Why was that important?
This is like kind of strange.
So, I somehow knew that,
first of all, I train with guys, I like side tons of guys,
there was like five people
in that senior team that were girls,
the rest were dudes.
My brothers, where I grew up around guys,
like a lot of guy cousins.
I just, I liked that energy for training
I didn't even know what it was like
to really train with all girls,
so I was sort of just biased right off the start.
But I also knew that the men back strokers
in the 200, were equivalent
to why I wanted to be in the 200 free.
I didn't know times, but I remember my brother saying to me,
if you wanna go really fast in you're 200 free,
you need to train with dudes in the 200 back.
'Cause it's the same time and I was like,
whatever that means.
But so, I checked the box of looking
at University of Florida, palm trees
like Mike De Boer best friend Martyn Wilby
was one of the coaches.
Men and women's team warm weather
and a lot of male backstroker so I can train with them.
Isn't that weird?
And I ended up doing it my whole career.
Right, well you're somebody who has a lot of guy friends
it feels like most of your friends are dudes.
So not, I think, the word masculine
has a pejorative when used
in association with somebody who's a woman,
but there's like a, there is a masculine aspect
to how you carry yourself socially.
Yeah, I like to hang.
Yeah, and you're super tight with your brother.
Yeah and I really needed that experience.
And I wanted that experience.
And then he ended up going there.
And that was like--
He transfer, though, right?
Yeah, there's a lot that went on with that.
Just a lot of yeah, there's a lot that went on with that.
But Greg Troy, recruited me to University of Florida,
and he was my main coach throughout the years there.
And that, that's the whole up and down relationship
between him and I.
But yeah, so I went to University of Florida
end up signing with them full scholarship.
Went in my freshman year.
Oh, man, I had the best freshman year,
out of all the years really, actually.
200 free 500 free at SECs, won them at SECs
with second in both at NCAA's.
And then my sophomore year came around,
and I had so many expectations,
and I just swam like crap.
I mean, it was a rough year for me.
So what was the change?
Like, what do you attribute that dip to?
Expectations so--
So suddenly, you're this artistic personality
who kind of just goes with the flow
and suddenly you're in a position
where you're actually paying attention
to all that stuff that everybody
had been telling you all along,
that you needed to pay attention to
and it had the opposite effect.
Yeah, so all of a sudden,
I had to pay attention to times like you said.
And coming in as a freshman,
there's no expectation, it's just, go.
And Greg Tory put a lot of pressure on me my sophomore year,
he also had me training in the distance group.
So Anthony Nesty was my coach and Nesty is amazing.
He's the greatest human.
But every day I'd walk on the pool deck
on the outdoor pool deck where the distance group trained,
and he would say, "Why are you out here?
"I don't know why you're out here."
And I was like, I don't either.
I don't, I cannot do four 1000s for time,
that's not the way I train.
So, I started doing this distance training
and stepping out of the weight room
and then into the pool more and training straight distance
and my body didn't respond.
I have pretty sensitive adrenals and so it was like, boom,
I was, severely underweight, I wasn't training well,
I wasn't competing well, I got sick a few times.
And I was also in unhealthy relationship
for the first year of my life
and so it was just like, coming from every angle
it was like the great storm of, oh, dear God,
like now I have to prove myself
and people don't like me again
and I'm not well and I don't know what to do.
Was there pressure to lose weight?
Yeah.
Every day I went on the pool deck,
I was told, either tighten it up
or go on an extra run this week or,
there were specific groups for extra runs and stuff,
and I was not anywhere near needing to do an extra run.
And that was a really, really hard time for me.
I didn't know either how to,
I didn't have a voice, I didn't speak up,
I didn't say a damn word.
'Cause I believed in what was going on.
I believed in it.
And I just remember being so confused.
Like, I don't understand why I'm being told these things
why am I not enough?
So we're back to that again.
Yeah, well, you have a certain level of success,
you're this big fish in a small pond in Kentucky,
but then, for people that are unfamiliar,
like the University of Florida was a mecca of swimming.
You were in that bubble pool, right?
Yeah.
That epic
architectural pool that.
Is that still there?
I love that pool.
There is a little five lane outdoor pool,
Right, Greg Troy legendary coach
Anthony Nesty Olympic gold medalist in 100 fly
from Suriname.
I remember they when he won the gold medal,
they like they put him on the currency.
Like he was such a national hero.
Oh, yeah, he would go back for parades
and they parade him around in a chair the whole deal.
And he married this beautiful, tall, redhead woman
and they had the most amazing little girl.
I mean, he was just fantastic.
And honestly, unfortunately,
he was the distance coach didn't have a lot of interaction
with him after sophomore year.
What was the decision that you needed to go
into the distance program?
because I mean, that ends up being your thing,
but that wasn't what you arrived thinking
you were gonna be doing.
He wanted me to swim the mile.
He wanted me to --
Because?
I don't know.
I really don't know.
Well, he's kinda right.
I mean, I was good at the 500.
That was the--
800 meters still.
Yeah, but I wasn't mentally a miler.
That wasn't my thing.
I was a very much 500 that went
toward the 200 and not the other way.
But I mean, the amount we trained,
John's interview with you, oh, my God,
I mean, we were training four times a day.
Four times a day?
Yeah, we had morning practice,
we had weights and dry land,
and we had afternoon practice.
So morning, go to class, go to weights,
go back to dry land to go to afternoon practice.
Eat go to bed.
So two full sessions
and two gym sessions every day.
And I was tapped.
And you're looking
maybe 15,000 yards a day or something.
Some days, way more.
But I was just tapped, and so I think there was a belief
that I needed more training.
And I remember one day,
I walked into the pool deck sophomore year
and it was like, four 2000, no nine 1650s.
And yeah, I mean, I'm not kidding, Rich
I start crying, immediately start like,
and I was I didn't know what to do.
1650 is a mile.
So nine, nine one mile repeats in the pool.
I mean, let's put it this way.
It takes from two until like seven.
So I just start crying.
Unlike, the 18 minutes or something like that.
And so Nesty comes up to me,
he puts his hands on my shoulders and he was like,
"You're gonna be okay."
I don't know if I am actually, lemme give this a try.
But they pulled me out at four.
So that day only did four but I'll never forget,
I got out at four and they still had five more it
they didn't finish like seven by the way 07:00 p.m.
And I called Mike de Boer.
And I'm sitting on the side of the pool outdoor pool,
like over in a corner on my little flip cell phone
it's like 2005 and a half or whatever.
And I just said something's not right.
I'm not doing what I need to be doing here,
something isn't right.
And he was just, he talked me through it.
What are you training?
What's going on?
Whatever.
I guess what happened was he ended up talking
to one of the coaches Wilby.
Wilby talked to Troy and it was like,
we need to switch around her training again.
Like she can't be training this way
it's not working for her.
So they ended up putting me back
in the weight room two extra days a week
and putting me in the middle distance group
and breaststroke group, brushwork I am
and I started swimming way better with the lights out.
So, the balance of that but also I think
as I sort of have reflected on that
feeling seen from Mike
and then having a conversation with my coach
and connecting on that level,
and having a real conversation
about what's happening with my body,
why my cycles are gone, why I'm sick all the time
why my blood work sucks,
like getting real with the actual biological effects
of what's gone on inside my body without over training
was eye opening for them and also, for me.
I've never been over trained before,
really like I didn't understand what that felt like.
So that really was a the first time in my life,
I saw the combination of the mind body working together
to kind of pivot me back on course.
I didn't have that connection before,
I always, so to kind of refer back
to what I was saying earlier.
I always sort of felt weird, 'cause I had that innately.
I knew that I was a semantic experiencer
and I felt things in my body
but I didn't understand that the brain
and the body were working together to feel things
and that where you feel one you feel the other.
It's very similar to John Moffat's trajectory.
'Cause he was, a guy who couldn't handle
that kind of volume, but had the self awareness
and the boundaries, the healthy boundaries
to say I'm not going to that morning workout,
it's not in service to the goals that I've set
or of the team.
And I think people don't understand how difficult
it is to create that boundary
because you're a part of this program that's legendary
and this is what we do here.
So get in the pool and don't ask questions.
I used to have my academic advisor, Tim,
pull me out of workouts,
'cause he knew how drained and tired I was,
my grades were suffering.
And he would just have me sit in the OSL,
the Office of Student Life over in the corner
and tell coach that I had a tutor, quote/unquote.
'Cause I was so drained, yeah, I would just sleep.
And it takes a long time to emerge out of that.
Super long, I felt very guilty
held a lot of guilt there,
'cause it felt like everyone else's training,
but I was also going through trauma,
like I was also going through a very unhealthy situation
with a relationship and so not only that,
my whole systems and sympathetic 24 seven,
showing up to the pool, with zero hours of sleep,
'cause I'm up all night before
going through whatever I'm going through,
and I get to the that
I wasn't even accounting for that.
I didn't realize how much that
was playing a part in my performance.
And it was like, eye opening to me
to finally realize that that was working against me.
All of these factors were working against me
and if I didn't align myself in the right path, mind
and body, I wasn't gonna go anywhere.
But you emerge out of that.
Yeah.
Senior year, NC Double A's
was like the big emergence out of it, I slowly emerged.
But that was my, probably my favorite part.
Was that 2008?
So 2008, you break a (indistinct) record in the 500 Free?
And that was the longest standing record at the time,
right it was a Janet Evans?
Yeah.
I mean, that's pretty epic.
That was my favorite performance of my life.
It was like 433, or something like that?
Yeah, and I ripped two suits before that
and I remember just being totally in flow, like,
I don't remember that race at all.
I touched the wall, and I had oodles of energy,
I could have gone for another 500.
And I remember just being like, holy shit,
trials are in three months, I'm gonna do this.
I remember that thought
going through my min the moment that I touched the wall.
I'm going to the Olympics.
Yeah, and also, with that comes a lot of, pressure.
But that moment was really powerful for me,
because it was the first time that I felt like I really
hit that stride of feeling in flow
and seeing the struggle throughout my college career
come to a place where I could put aside these distractions
that I had, going on at the exact same time
and use the tools that I had to make something happen.
it felt like--
What were the what were those tools specifically
at that time?
I went from not doing any sort of mindset work at all,
or really understanding what that was
to focusing in on that kind of stuff.
Breath work, I don't know if you'd call it meditation
but I journal I'd--
Visualization.
Imagery, I wrote all my goals and images in pictures
and none of my goals were in times,
my locker had the pictures or an icon
of something like banana,
banana reminded me of like, whatever I want to do was,
I was weird.
So that was a big factor in that.
Those tools, but also, I think I felt very aligned
with Coach Troy at that time,
because right before that year,
we had a huge, conversation about the way I perform
what I need to go and do in practice.
And a lot of that stemmed around
tempo work visualization work.
Our conversations were about that,
he saw me, for the first time in that relationship
as a coach to swimmer
and I was able to really turn that around.
And so I think it was the connection with him,
the connection that I felt
finally, after however many years
I'm feeling--
Trust?
This connection with this person.
Yeah, trust, communication, clarity.
And, so instead of this resistance that we had,
like, he doesn't get me, I don't get her, he doesn't get me,
I don't get her, it was like, one conversation,
one, two hour conversation
could really change the trajectory of what I was gonna do
based on sharing what works for me,
and how I can be a better student
of whatever it is that I need to get done
through the methods that my brain understands
the learning styles,
my brains--
So forming some
kind of partnership.
Yeah.
Type of relationship.
So trials comes up three months later.
Three months later.
It's an interesting one,
because you end up making the Olympic team
by getting fourth in the 200 Free style.
But you got a bunch of fours, right?
And a fifth.
And 103, 403.
I barely, and then I would have meddled
at the actual Olympics with the times I went, so I know.
It was a pretty--
It's like, yeah,
it's gotta be like mixed emotions,
'cause you didn't actually qualify in an individual event.
You were just one place shy of getting that.
You still medal at the Olympics in the relay.
You swam, the preliminaries, and then
also on the final, so they bumped you up.
Yeah.
Did you just rock out a split they didn't expect or?
Yeah, so this is where things kinda get interesting.
My Olympic trials was a pretty emotional ride for me.
I was going through like the thick of
some traumatic experiences, literally,
at the trials, like, in the process of that mean.
Relationship stuff?
Yeah
So I think, as I've as I've worked through that, too,
that is where some of that resentment and shame comes from,
because I think to myself, could I have been better
had I not, had that kind of experience.
Distracted by a boyfriend situation
that wasn't working out?
Yeah
So let's see, I made it in the well,
the 400 Free, I missed it by a spot 200 free, I made it.
And then the 100 free, and the 800 Free,
I was like, fifth fourth, something like that.
And the trials are so intense.
It's the most intense me way more intense in the Olympics.
But, gearing up toward the Olympics,
this was the year that prelims were at night,
and finals were in the morning in Beijing.
So, really having to change how I trained like,
I was a night swimmer, now it had to be a both swimmer.
I had to be a morning, a prelim, a final, the whole thing.
But that was, it was a really important time.
Olympic trials were a really important time
to get to the to the games,
I think, I wish I would have made it
in individual event, for sure, I still feel that.
But I also am so proud of myself
for how I handled everything else that was going on
and the way that I was able
to show up during the darkest part of my life.
I was in the darkest one of the darkest parts
of my life before I even made the team.
And so, yes, the transition was really dark,
but that part right before was really hard
to pull myself out of--
Were you keeping
all that private, though,
or were you letting people help you?
I had one person helping me, my counselor at school.
I didn't talk to anybody about it.
My parents had no idea my teammates and my roommates knew
'cause they lived with me.
But I didn't have any conversations with people about it.
And Greg brighter Troy didn't know, or?
They did but, I think it's--
Complicated.
Yeah, they can't do anything about it.
So when you reflect back on your Olympic experience,
I mean, ow do you think about it now versus then?
I feel like it was the beginning of my life,
in a weird way.
Like, it was like the first of so much to come.
And it was a springboard for sure,
for a lot of different reasons.
But it was the beginning of my life in that,
I was able to look, I'm able to look at it
and know that I have sort of been reborn again,
from that experience.
Like I was a certain way leading up to it.
And that's experience happens.
And it's easy for people to say,
sure you go to the Olympics, of course, you're reborn,
it's this big achievement.
But personally, internally,
the way my nervous system was wired,
the way my whole body and my being are in this world,
was able to sort of start there and say,
what's been working and what hasn't?
And, how can I go from here?
Did I know that at the time?
No.
Did I know that 10 years after?
Do I look at it now and say, oh, wow,
that was a beautiful thing.
And I'm so glad that I can look at
that experience and say, holy shit,
I stood on the podium in front of the world
and also can see every age of Caroline Burckle.
Two, four, six, eight, 10, 12, every age of myself there
howing up to that podium,
every single age until that moment.
And that's really special.
Because to me, it doesn't symbolize this, 200 Free.
Yeah, that's great.
But it's, to get there, it took all versions of me.
And then to go from there,
it's gonna take a whole different, Caroline.
And I think that feeling and that realization
is powerful to feel that you can have stages
of your life like that.
What do people not fully understand
about the Olympic experience.
I mean, I suspect it's gotta be disorienting to go from,
churning out sets in Gainesville
to suddenly being foisted onto the international stage
and being on television, in a bathing suit.
For all the world to cast its their judgments
on and their opinions.
It's definitely, it really challenges, your focus,
it challenges your ability to stay in your lane,
and to be able to block things out really well.
Especially with media and with with other things going on.
Luckily, then we didn't have a lot of media.
There wasn't we didn't have phones at the Olympics.
We didn't have phones.
Facebook was online,
but it wasn't there was no iPhone or anything like that.
No social media, no iPhones,
we didn't have any technology in the village.
The village is a very, dense experience,
there's just a lot of people obviously vying
for the same thing. so the energy is just palpable
you can feel it from everybody.
But there's also this camaraderie, it's beautiful.
You see every country and every walk of life,
and it's a really special experience.
And you see a lot that you've never seen before.
As girl from Kentucky and Florida.
And I mean, I'm seeing the world, right,
you're seeing the world right in front of you
and you have to really check yourself
with what you've, been thinking your whole life
and put your judgment aside and be able to hone in
on really what you're doing accept everybody,
and kind of move forward.
That's the point of the Olympics, right?
Is to accept everybody.
The rings symbolize that unity of the world together.
So it is a special experience ,
where you're trying to compete against each other,
but you're really trying to bring everybody together
of the world into this special place to achieve this goal.
Do you feel like in the wake of
that you you departed Beijing thinking, I'm just starting,
I got a bunch of force and I was on this relay
and I got a medal but my individual time
would have meddled in this event, I'm getting back to work?
No.
I knew I was bummed that I couldn't get meddled on my own,
but I was so burned out at that point,
I was beyond ready to walk away and to run away.
I was listening to Apollo's podcast with you
and he just, some of the things he said struck a chord too,
just with, the weight of gold and how that all works.
And we can go down that path, but,
it's a whole experience of what now?
And that's the easy way to say it.
But there really is no better way to say it.
It's daunting, and also, you can't be bothered
to go back into the fires.
And they are like, we're so good as athletes at focusing,
and at pivoting our focus.
So we pivot to running, and you don't look back that way,
'cause it really damn good at what you do.
So you're gonna focus this way instead of focusing.
But you don't know what to focus that spotlight on,
that's the problem.
And on paper, like from a academic perspective,
who wouldn't wanna hire an Olympian,
these people know how to work hard,
they know how to set a goal,
they know how to achieve it,
they know how to show up under pressure
and overcome obstacles.
They just seem like the ultimate candidate
for the marketplace, but it doesn't work that way.
And I think the more often than not,
it is the weight of gold, where they become,
they have this existential crisis,
like, what am I supposed to do now?
I've never thought about this,
because getting to where they got
to achieve what they achieved required every ounce
of focus and discipline and intention.
There just wasn't any time to ponder what comes after.
And there aren't structures in place
to help athletes with that transition.
So, that's why I think that movie
was so powerful and instructive.
It was incredible.
I watched it a few times, and was just sobbing my eyes down.
Because, again, it goes back to that same conversation
of how can you be feeling two things at once,
so proud, like, sick, Lolo Jones, like sick,
I just want this medal, and also, I'm making smoothies,
So it's like, how can you be so angry,
and harbor this anger and frustration at what you've done?
And also be so proud and so excited
that you've done this thing
and can't wait to like, tell your friends?
Like, even though they know.
I can't wait to do all these other things.
And--
You can't tell your friends
that you feel that way?
No, so much shame with that.
Because they would think you're an entitled spoiled brat.
Or, that was my story.
No one wants to hear that sob story,
and Michael Phelps says it really well, too,
he says the same thing.
I couldn't possibly tell people I was depressed,
I had 700 gold medals.
There's no way I could tell somebody that I'm depressed.
There's no way that I could share,
that I've had suicidal thoughts.
There's no way that I could share that
I was in a traumatic situation or relationship.
There's no way that I could share that,
God, that I hated myself at a certain part of,
day four at the Olympics.
There's no way you can share these specific feelings.
Because what, then?
what would what would people think of you?
Right, you're you're a bulletproof Olympian?
Yeah, you gotta be Superman.
You've gotta be this special force
that, people would kill to be in your shoes.
And so yeah, you could never say something
that would jeopardize your Olympic status.
Because then if people find out
and not only people, but media,
let's say media finds out there,
oh, she's complaining about--
She's got a bad attitude.
Yeah, she's got a bad attitude.
So there's--
She's a bad Olympian.
Right. and the, the psychology of it
is changing, because I think there's a lot
of awareness now around the fact
that you can be depressed or having a difficult time
or going through something traumatic
and also perform.
That both of those are okay.
Again, back to the two things.
Yeah, well I mean, I think, Michael is to be credited,
considerably for the work that he's done
to expand that awareness.
Huge.
And--
I mean,
were you were on the Olympic team with him,
is there, you've spent a lot of time with him, I presume.
Yeah, he's great .
Was there any into, like,
I'm sure your your, your relationship with him
is when you're at swim Meets.
So could see that aspect of it?
Yeah know, and we saw it was Michael though,
just because he's,
he's vulnerable, he could show he wears his emotions,
on a sleeve and so you could see him struggling,
but you don't know to what extent.
You don't know if that's just,
at that point time we're also laser focused.
You don't know if that's just with training
or with not going times you wanna go,
whatever it is, you just assume that
that person is struggling for another reason.
Not with worth, even though I was struggling with worth.
So, it's like you can feel it,
but we just never It was like hushed,
but no one would ever utter those words.
We all feel this way, but no one's saying anything.
So he was like the cats out of the bag,
he broke the mold there have.
We've all been feeling this,
and somebody just needs to say it
'cause we're all feeling it and walking around
with this like weird thing where everyone's awkward
and Oh yeah, I'm great, how are you?
I'm great, years later, and that's not the case.
Like, let's just say it how it is
and also you can be struggling and be proud
of your experience at the same time.
No one's telling you, you can't have both.
And I think that a lot of us felt like
we couldn't have both.
So you kinda cut and run, right?
Like you just you just walk away from the pool
for a little while, I mean, you found your way back to it,
but you took this break.
So I cut and run.
I didn't look one direction from a pool for years.
First time I stepped inside
of a pool.
Years.
Years, probably two and a half.
I retired in 2010.
First time I stepped foot back
into a pool was Clark's Olympic trials.
And that was like, really hard for me.
I cried so much at that Meet by myself
in the hotel room in Omaha.
And I was so proud of my brother,
I have never seen a better race
than his race to make the Olympic team
in that 200 breaststroke is hands down
the best underwater pullout kid in the world.
I mean, he's insane, he's so strong.
And I was so proud of him
and so emotional there at that Meet.
Of course, I didn't show anybody I cried my hotel room.
'Cause of course--
Brother, sister duo's,
that have both become Olympians, there must be?
Crippen's, I believe.
Or no, maybe I'm thinking of something.
I don't know.
I don't think so.
Maybe another sports.
In swimming, there's sisters like Haley and Alyssa Anderson.
No, but that was, that was the first time
so you can imagine I ran away and the first time I come back
is around the exact same world,
the world I ran away from it.
And I had a purpose.
My purpose was to support my brother.
So I was able to again, block out my stuff,
handle it on my own and be there for him.
And I traded that whole Olympic trials,
like I was competing, my ass was up at 04:00 a.m
going on a run, getting ready eating breakfast,
like the whole, like, I felt like I was in the experience,
but I was not experience like I wasn't in that experience.
But so he makes the team and then we go to London.
And that again, it's like my second Meet back.
And that was really difficult for me.
So throughout this whole process,
difficult but proud.
So I mean, I can't tell you,
I was way more proud of my brother than I ever was myself.
It's crazy how that works.
And I get to oh, well throughout that process,
I was like struggling with some body dysmorphia,
some disordered eating, wasn't healthy,
let's put it that way,
at all, like just full stop, wasn't healthy,
wasn't eating wasn't taking care of myself,
didn't feel worthy of love, period.
Didn't have that my system had been in overdrive
and had been in sympathetic literally, for years.
And I had not come down.
My body was churning every last morsel of energy
just to get through that Meet.
And I got back from that Meet and I just like,
crashed, like my sit, my body just started to break down
it was this whole thing with that.
But that was the that was sort of the first realization
that I had that I wasn't healthy.
So between 2008 the Olympics,
you walking away from the sport and 2012
when you you don't really return to swimming,
but you return to the culture,
to support your brother a lot, there's a lot that happened.
So I wanna spend a little bit of time here.
I mean, you end up,
you're trying to find your way you get a fashion degree,
you got to fit them, right,
and you're working with some apparel brands
and you're employed, you're tryna figure it out.
But I feel like there's a crucial event
that takes place that I think,
puts you deeper into that psychological hole
and that happens around 2010.
So can we talk about that a little bit?
Yeah, so I had transferred from
the FIDM OC campus to the LA campus.
So I was living with Haley Piersol.
And Aaron came to visit for three months.
Classic Aaron move.
Is he's like living in Costa Rica now or something.
I guess, yeah.
But he came to live with us.
He just lived with us, I was on the corner
of La Cienega and again in Olympic.
What am I doing here?
Right in LA?
Oh my God.
And I was working for Lululemon.
I just like, I didn't know what to do.
So, I was sitting in my apartment one night,
and I get like, multiple calls in on my phone
one after the next I'm like
who is this unknown number
I don't understand what's going on.
And then I got a bunch of text messages
and voicemails that were left
and I had just retired from something
so literally a month retired, fresh.
I had been training, for context
at Fullerton Aquatic Club with Sean Hutchison.
And--
And what was the intention
of the training at that time?
'Cause this is to that is two years after the Olympics.
Were you thinking you're,
was it because you just couldn't let go of it
and didn't know what else to do?
Or did you have designs on some some lofty goals?
I was just running,
I was chasing different things
to check off the list that I could just do.
Like I needed something to feel worthy.
I needed something to show.
So I just kept doing things.
I was collecting accolades and degrees and all these things.
And I was like, oh, yeah,
I'll just do all these things, distract myself.
You're living on a Olympic in La Cienega.
You're driving to Fullerton to swim.
I mean, that's a hike.
Yeah, I mean, I did that just until I retired.
And then I was like I can't do this anymore,
'cause you had to transfer campus for it for Fullerton.
I got it.
But, I felt like I just had to prove myself in the sport.
I felt like I needed to finish it off and prove myself.
And when I retired, I retired at Irvine Nationals,
I knew my last race, I knew going into it.
I knew the moment I did the 200 free
I was in lane one, I swam horrible,
I got out I started, went to the diving,
I put my goggles on, try to not let anybody see me cry.
And Amanda Beard, of course,
comes over and puts her arm on my shoulder
and, she was an angel for me my whole career by the way.
She was an angel at the training camp
with some coach situations, she was an angel
afterward, she just said like, you're gonna be okay.
You may not know what you're gonna do,
but you're gonna be okay.
And I was like, okay,
and this is coming from somebody
that started the sport seven different times
and had a crazy cool career and child and all these things.
And so I just let it be,
and I just walked away from the sport.
And walked away from the sport 'cause I
was tired of the politics and the feelings that I got
about my worth as a human being and my body
and my, I was just tired I just needed to get away.
It was so exhausting to always feel like I was like,
an object of a project or something that I couldn't,
I couldn't figure out
how to find my love for it again.
So, why not just run away?
I don't wanna keep trying and forcing
this if I'm just gonna feel angry at it.
And that was my reason for stopping I was tired,
I was tired I was tired of what was going on,
I was tired of feeling like I was just,
like I said this object or this project or not enough
or needed to be somebody for these coaches
or these people I just like wanted to be.
And it was such a powerful feeling within me
that I was just so tired of that
and so I just ran away
and that's when I had a lot of different things happening.
But I fully ended my career
on a very intense like
bodily feeling that I have to go.
I had to go like it was just too much for me.
And also like that I knew that I did
I got out what I put in, that I got what I came for
I did what I wanted to do--
On the pool deck.
Yeah.
Oh, I just feel it in my body when I talk
about that moment.
I can see that.
That was so powerful it was,
I was sitting on the side of the pool
and I was ending this thing
it's like you're breaking up with
this thing you've been with for 25 years or whatever
and it was just this is how it is?
This is how it's gonna end
just like petering out in a local Meet.
In a subpar performance.
Subpar performance really not good
and proud of myself for continuing,
but, I just wanted to prove myself.
And when I realized that,
I just didn't need to be in it anymore.
I needed to find something else
and I knew that I could.
And I knew that I could could be rebirth in my life.
And I had that feeling that that would happen.
I just didn't know how.
I no idea how, I didn't no idea what I was gonna do.
Well, you move to La Cienega, Olympic
and start working for Lululemon, apparently.
And then I walked the Santa Monica stairs every day
as my workouts
Yeah, so I moved there, I live with Haley.
And then Aaron came to came to live with us.
And I was just very depressed during that time.
I don't really recall any moments that felt like,
pure joy for me, I was really struggling during that time.
It was really hard for me.
And it's why I started to hide, I started to inch my way
into the little hole, step by step.
And it was right around this time
that you got this evening occurred
where you get these weird text messages.
Yeah.
And that felt like the last straw for me.
That was like the last straw for me.
So I get.
So explain, explain what happened?
Yeah.
So my coach Sean from FAST,
was out with Coach Bowman one night,
and I guess, whatever they were doing,
they decided to send me some vulgar text messages
and voicemails, and it involved myself, my brother
and just things that were very traumatizing for me
as a 23 year old girl that had just retired from the sport
and also run away from that exact thing,
that exact experience of,
abuse in a lot of ways.
And so I was just done, that moment was traumatizing for me.
And it felt like my initial reaction
was that I needed to turn them in.
So I turned messages in.
Right, so let's just contextualize it a little bit.
Sean Hutchinson, this is from coach at FAST.
And, was a well regarded coach
who had birthed many a career.
Bob Bowman is famous for being Michael Phelps' coach.
So you get these weird text messages from unknown numbers
and it turns out, it's Bob and Sean,
and they're off color,
they're off putting their distasteful,
we don't need to get into exactly what they said,
but there's articles out there,
if you wanna read about it.
It's been reported in the press.
But it was highly, highly inappropriate.
And it also was a glimpse into,
some things that Sean had been doing
that he shouldn't have been doing with a friend of yours,
a swimmer Ariana Kukors,
that then kind of precipitated after you report this,
a whole kind of scandal with USA Swimming,
not just with respect to Sean and his relation,
his inappropriate relationship with with Ariana,
and the kind of legal actions that took place
in the wake of that,
but also more broadly, about how USA Swimming
deals with these sorts of situations historically.
So--
So you get
these weird text messages, in them you respond,
and you're like, this isn't funny, bah, bah, bah,
and you report it at the time, right?
So that is this, like, 2011 2010.
2000 of the beginning of 11 or the middle of 10.
What is the USA Swimming say to you?
So I turn them in and, admittedly,
following my classic Caroline pattern,
my first message to them was,
please just do what you need to do and leave me out of this.
I don't wanna make anybody upset.
And that was my first reaction.
By being the people pleaser that you are,
I suspect it was even a struggle for you
to decide to report them to begin with?
Very, very difficult.
Despite it being so highly inappropriate.
Very difficult.
Aaron actually was the one that encouraged me to do it.
He's an advocate for it,
like what's right in USA Swimming, and he's,
he's been fantastic with that.
And so I said, okay, look, I'll do it.
I didn't wanna anybody,.
So I turn them in and I remember them asking me
if I wanted to appear on a call,
so I appeared on a call Sean didn't show.
Bob did show and he was apologetic and the whole thing.
And that was that,
there was never anything else done about it.
And that I think--
Bob Bowman gets named
to be an Olympic coach the following year.
My brother coach.
And--
So nothing happens
to Bob Bowman at all, except maybe
some stern words from Frank bush and that's kinda it.
Yeah, that was it.
And, of course I was so,
I don't know if the word traumatized is correct
but it's really the only word that comes up for me,
that I just was, like, sure you guys do it,
I just wanna stay out of it,
please just leave me out of it.
I didn't feel I had a voice to even
insert myself into this situation
and share how I felt and what my thoughts
were and what my feelings were.
And I since have felt more empowered
to talk about that,
and how it's absolutely not okay.
And it just shouldn't happen across the board.
But man, did I just not feel
like I had any voice in that at all.
There was no--
And when you raise
your voice, it didn't seem like it had any impact.
I mean, Sean ended up paying
a greater price for good reason.
But none of this was reported until 2018.
So you do this, and then it's all kind of
dealt with behind the scenes,
Eight years later.
On one level
or another until 2018 when the OC Register
of all publications, does this deep dive,
investigative journalism into the story
and the story breaks in this local paper,
and then it becomes like a national story.
Yeah, and that rocked me.
Like, that rocked me.
'Cause I had never I ran away from it.
I ran away from everything for those eight years,
every single thing that occurred in my life,
that was not okay, from, a coach or a relationship or,
basically those two things,
I ran away from it all
'cause I didn't know how to address it.
I was sheepish, I didn't know how to even say anything.
It wasn't a big deal to speak up, then either.
People don't do that people never really did that.
Women didn't really speak up.
I mean, Allie Raisman sort of put that on the map, right?
Where you're just like, this isn't okay,
I'm gonna stand up for what's right
and you can't be speaking like this to young women.
And I understood that I was 23,
and then I was a little bit older,
and I was retired, quote/unquote,
but the the idea is that
these things shouldn't be happening at all
because if they're thinking then
it was being thought when I was a swimmer.
And being not just 'cause it wasn't acted on,
that doesn't mean it's still okay.
And so, and nothing happened until 2018.
And that was when they dug up all
that stuff for Ariana's case, and they called me.
And, they were like, did this happen to you?
And I'm like, yeah, of course,
I turned in the information like, what's going on?
I was startled, totally like what's going on?
Well, this is so and so I need to know this
'cause you're under investigation
'cause we found files from Sean toward you.
And I was just in that moment,
Rich, like my whole being shut down.
Because my body and fighter flight was just like,
oh, my God, you're gonna die.
That was how I reacted
and I was just literally on my apartment.
My like, second apartment in LA,
my floor for a straight week.
I don't think I ate one meal.
I was on the phone with Jack every day,
like all day, I don't think I drank any water.
I don't think I went out of my apartment.
I was ordering in anything I needed.
I didn't want to be seen, it was all of a sudden, like,
I was the bad guy, that was my view of it.
Is that I was now the bad guy.
And I oh.
Because Bowman's this huge hero.
Yeah, and I respected him as a coach.
I really, really did.
And I didn't have any that was a shock from him.
I didn't have any problems with Bob,
so that was a shock from him.
From Sean, no.
But--
Yeah, for people that are listening,
I mean, Sean, it turns out
had developed a highly inappropriate relationship
with Ariana beginning when she was 13 years old,
like grooming her, sexually assaulting her at 16 I believe,
ultimately getting banned from the sport.
I think they just settled the civil lawsuit.
I don't know if there's any update
on what's going on with that guy.
No one knows where he is.
But he's not
in sport anymore.
But short of that story coming out in 2018,
this was all being dealt with surreptitiously,
which is kind of par for the course for USA Swimming
that time and time again, has to weather these scandals
and you would think they would learn their lesson
and figure out a way to deal with this stuff aboveboard,
but they seem to continue to trip on themselves
and handle it miserably.
And it's really reprehensible and inexplicable.
I mean, I guess I can understand these people
who are trying to cover their ass
and keep these things from being public scandals.
But they consistently seem to do the wrong thing here.
And this dates back decades.
And I think we've talked about this,
I don't know if this,
but my high school girlfriend was Kelly Davies
and she was sexually harassed by ours swim coach Rick Curl,
that was going on while I was in a relationship with her.
This is like back in the, like the early, mid 80s.
And, it was a very different time back then.
That was settled civilly, privately for like, $150,000,
back in like 1988, or '86, or something like that.
And resurface many years later, because Kelly,
for reasons that I'm sure you can relate to,
had a lot of unresolved trauma over this.
And when she saw Rick Curl,
when she turned on the television
to watch Olympic trials on the deck,
and it occurred to her like, this guy's still coaching
and nobody knows what happened because this was dealt with
in the way that it was dealt with.
It became an intolerable situation.
And, she alerted USA Swimming,
I don't think that they dealt with it
as well as they should have at the time.
Ultimately, it all came to light,
because the Washington Post,
like the OC Register caught on to the story
and decided to, pull on a few threads,
and expose the whole thing,
which ultimately led to Rick Curl going to jail.
But this was so long after the fact.
And it was something that I'm sure USA Swimming thought
was in the past and these things,
tend to not go away unless they're dealt
with swiftly and responsibly.
What you don't deal with will always come back,
and across the board, it always comes back full circle,
like things that aren't dealt with,
whether it's personally or within an organization
or whatever it is, it's gonna come back around,
it's not just gone.
And I think I always had a feeling it would,
I just didn't know when.
I always felt like how is this it?
Like this can't really that can't be it, right?
Like something has to come to the surface
with this even if it's just bylaws and different things
that come out that are governing the
whole coaching body as USA Swimming coaching body
as a whole, like what do they need to do in order
to pass certain ethical standard
Well, they seem to kind of adhere to the letter
of the law, but not the spirit of the law.
Like they have the hotline,
you can call if if something happens
and you can report it.
But in the case of Sean,
didn't the USA swimming's General Counsel
like appointed this former FBI investigator
to do the sort of roll up your sleeves work
and interview all these witnesses,
but they ended up shutting her down.
And in the case of Hutchinson,
she was deprived of being able to
interview certain critical people
including like Terry Torres in this situation.
So the true story is never fully documented
for the public record.
Yeah, and there's just I had to commute
to Long Beach multiple times to do different things
with lawyers and all this,
I was just, and I felt like how's this ever gonna be okay?
There's so many layers to this, so many people
have these stories and these things about multiple people,
in USA, swimming and in USA Gymnastics,
and all these sports and these NGBs
it's like, there's so much it's going on.
And also great coaches,
I mean, my club coach, oh, my gosh,
this gave me upmost respect for him.
But something's gotta change.
And it's, as we talked about with everything,
it's gotta kinda wipe the system clean and start over.
And that's the hard part,
is where do you even how do you even do that
when there's been legends floating around forever?
But, back to what you were saying
about people just try and cover things up,
I think everybody was just afraid to upset someone else
who's afraid to upset someone else
who's afraid to upset someone else.
So everything just got swept under.
And then there's you,
who doesn't wanna upset anybody, either.
So you've suffered the trauma of having,
been in the middle of that experience itself
and then there's the trauma of,
now this is public I'm a people pleasing person
who doesn't wanna rock the boat and wants to be well liked,
and now all this attention is being directed at me.
And, it's not just the text messaging,
it's there's other stuff that goes on
that people don't know,
comments on pool deck and little emails here and there.
And that, it's like all different things
throughout my career that I had to
not only dig up and turn in,
but say, out loud, and that in itself
is like a whole trauma re-experience.
that whole thing was just really flooded me.
And this was like, what, two years ago?
Three years ago?
Two
Two, march of 2018.
Gosh, it feels like too long ago.
But the act of actually becoming aware,
it's kind of interesting.
The awareness piece in sport is huge, right?
Like you hear (indistinct) talk about like,
awareness is everything.
Because I was so aware, and then I pushed it down.
When I became aware again,
and everything rose to the surface.
It was like, my whole world was just like, holy crap.
Because you hadn't done anything to heal
from any of that you've just been compartmentalizing it.
Compartmentalizing it, coping all my coping strategies
with food and with exercise.
And I became so obsessed with these other things,
in order to feel like I could run
from the things that had really hurt me
that started with this pattern way long ago,
and just carried on throughout my life.
It's like not these little symptoms of things,
it's like this underlying thing
that I just couldn't speak up about,
or I was afraid to, hurt people's feelings.
So I never did any of these things.
And when all that was unpacked,
and my awareness was so high, and my senses were out,
and I was so in tune with what was going on,
holy crap this is a big deal Caroline,
like you've been pushing down a lot of stuff.
That was like, a whole tornado of things in my life.
It felt like my life was ending to be honest,
like at that time in 2018, I was like,
I've been essentially abused for a really long time
and I haven't even been able to say that.
And I'm not tryna laugh at that,
but I'm just, of course, I'm not
but I get so shy saying that,
because I'm very sheepish at the fact
that I didn't see that.
That I didn't I wasn't aware of how not okay that was,
I thought it was normal to be given comments
on pool deck by a coach.
I thought it was normal to be sent secret emails,
I thought it was normal to have text message.
I thought that stuff was normal, it means they liked me.
And that's--
And this is what it took for you to confront that.
So on some level as painful and as uncomfortable
as it must have been, when all of this,
was revealed in the way that it was,
this compelled you to face these certain things
and wrestle with them so that you could ultimately heal.
Yeah, something had to crack.
Well, what's interesting is,
and I think we talked about this around this time,
'cause we had some communication when
these articles came out.
I was confused, because although it was picked up
by the media, it went from OC Register.
I mean, Sports Illustrated, ESPN wrote about it.
This was also kind of right in the thick of Ronan Farrow,
MeToo stuff as well and I thought
this was gonna blow up much bigger than it actually did.
Most people aren't even aware of this.
So did I.
It kind of went away?
And I think there's so much that has happened
in the swimming world
that hasn't even come to the surface that could.
I did, too, I did too and I think the anticipation
of that was terrifying, because being exposed like that,
is there's nothing worse.
There's nothing worse in the world
than opening up CNN and seeing your name
on the first headline.
I mean, I was sitting in my apartment on the floor,
just like, in total shock.
Like, what did I do wrong?
And that was that was where my brain was at.
But you must have been getting calls
and texts from friends
and getting a lot of support from people.
Tons of support, tons like, I mean,
through the roof letters, emails, this whole thing,
but at the same time, where I was at, still,
what did you do wrong, Caroline?
What people aren't gonna like you hear,
you're gonna lose, your friends will be gone
Oh, no, Michael doesn't know what
to say he you're gonna lose his friendship or Allison,
these people that were under Bob and all this
and I just felt so paranoid.
You won' be able to to have a relationship
with swimming again.
That it felt like--
You're not gonna be able
to show up on the pool deck at Olympic trials
to support your brother.
And that was everything like that,
that feeling that I was losing my world
and even though I had ran away from that world.
I was losing my world yet
I had been running away from it for eight years.
So I don't know why I thought it was losing it,
but to me, and I still like honestly, full disclosure,
full volume vulnerability here
I still have some days where I'm like, huh,
I wonder what they would think
of me if I just saw them at the airport?
Or, like would things be okay yet?
Like would things be normal?
If I ran into some of my friends or whatever
that I seemingly thought in my mind are mad at me
even though I know for a fact they're not.
But again, that pattern and why is it that's ingrained
in me that like, I've upset the men in power.
And that was that was the thing for me
was like these men I didn't want Bob
to be upset with me.
That was all I was telling Jack.
That was literally all I was telling Jack
was I just don't want Bob to be upset with me.
And he was like, he's not upset with you.
And what a Jack, yeah, what did Jack say.
Oh Jack is so supportive.
He's not upset with you, this isn't a Bob issue,
this is a Sean issue this isn't, also, this isn't okay.
So like, this isn't about that.
And like gearing me back toward away from my pattern
and toward the truth.
And also, like who cares?
And like, honestly, though,
and like I remember being like,
when I got to that point,
it was a very much a freeing feeling,
'cause I get so proud of how far I've come
in two years from that moment.
But I'm, I can take myself back to that feeling
and it's just so intense of how much people pleasing
played a role in justice and in truth.
My truth was tainted by people pleasing.
And your default setting to kind of defer to men in power.
That was--
So I wanna talk
about the two years since, because you've done a lot of work
to put yourself back together.
So I wanna get an understanding of
how you began that process and what it looked like for you?
'Cause I think this is a Olympics aside,
I think this is the the piece that
so many people are gonna be able to relate to.
Yeah, this is the meat and potatoes,
I guess you could say the most important part
about what I went through was asking for help.
I finally asked for help.
And I had been in and out of therapy for years,
leading up till this in 2018.
But it was coping, I learned how to cope really well.
I started to recognize right around the time
that this stuff came out in the news
that my body was telling me something.
So I hadn't had a period in 10 years.
10 years.
Maybe more.
Not one, like nothing.
So as a woman
2008 to 2018.
Yeah, as a woman, you're,
yes, exactly that long.
Your entire career.
My entire post one bit career.
And I had like, very irregular hormones
throughout my career as well, like very sporadic.
But the feeling as a woman of nothing vibrating
through your body, like no hormones, and you're just flat.
I was in complete dorsal state for this entire time
nothing, I couldn't cry, I couldn't cry at all.
I was like, barely emotional,
unless it was something gigantic.
But something that happened, I wouldn't cry
I was just flat, I was, I was kind of like,
dead in a way inside.
And, my body was very unhealthy I had disordered eating,
I wasn't eating I was doing different things
that were not healthy with my nutrition at all.
And my body started to break.
So as we know, I broke my heel,
right before Otillo, Rich
and I were gonna go head on over and (indistinct) Otillo
and I, or Otillu, however you say
(indistinct)
Every time I do that, though,
I get a bunch of messages from from people
in Sweden who are angry that I got it wrong.
So, I don't even try.
How do you say it?
It's something like (indistinct).
But we're just gonna be ugly Americans
and call it Otilla.
We're just gonna be ugly Americans.
You were gonna do it.
And then you me and went up to Donner like to train.
And you texted me like the day you were gonna go
and you said please come out, let's just do this.
And I'm like, but my heels broken, I'm a mess.
This thing just happened like what do I do.
I know but you need to come anyway.
And you were like, I don't think you understand
how God sent you were for me at that moment.
It was like somebody believed in me,
even though I was like on the ground
literally on the ground crying for--
I didn't know.
I didn't tell anybody.
I didn't show it.
I mean, I knew you were going through stuff,
but I just liked your energy and I wanted you around.
Yeah, and I loved you guys, so I was like sure I'm there.
So I go up there with my broken heel,
and that was the first sign that something was off.
But to me, it's just an injury, get through it, boom,
maybe you can go, whatever.
So we ended up going into that race.
I didn't do it Hillary ends up being pregnant,
so it was all a wash anyway.
It's perfect.
She was relieved when I told her she was like,
wait, I'm pregnant.
I was like, okay, great, so we're on the same page here.
So I healed up from that.
But the moment I healed up from
that I got septic knee in my right knee
from the ocean getting in after it rained,
I was in the hospital for three or four days.
The whole thing went into my body.
Your body was just saying Fuck you.
It was pissed.
You need to stop.
Yes, like you've been running?
Why are you still running?
Like, let's do something.
So--
I'm throwing all this stuff at you emotionally.
But you're still operating as if everything's normal.
So I'm going to I need to literally cut you off
at the knees in order for you to pay attention.
And did literally that.
And then the moment I get back from my, my knee,
I my broke my heel again.
And at that point, I was like, holy shit.
I think I get this.
And it was this light bulb that went off
that was like, okay, remember your career, Caroline
when you finally realize the mind body connection
and you realize I couldn't train that way,
if you needed to be, here and so you pivoted
and you did this, that's what's happening.
Your body is over trained and telling you something,
simplest terms at that point.
So what's going on?
Let's heal it.
So the second heal comes around.
Dr. Batten who's down the street here, he's amazing
he's our Olympic ortho.
He works for the Dodgers.
He looked at me and he was like,
you need to stop right now,
14 weeks on crutches and I was like,
no, I thought my life was over.
So 14 weeks or whatever the second time,
and I finally healed, I got my periods back.
I had started acupuncture,
and I started Somatic Experiencing therapy
all during this time.
So it this whole--
What is that?
Tell me what that is.
So it focuses on the nervous system.
So they basically it's not talk therapy,
so it's not just cognitive behavioral therapy.
It does like a rapid eye movement work
kinda takes you back into experiences of your life,
and you kind of heal them through
going back into them and then working through them.
It's nasty at first.
It's nasty, but you work you do the nervous system,
like it's through your nervous breathing
and meditation work, but you're working with somebody
this whole time, so it's not just talking and then leaving.
Which works, but, I think that's fantastic
for whoever's choosing to do that.
But for me personally as a feeler,
as I've explained here, it's like,
I feel, my body feels its way through performance,
it feels its way through everything I've done,
it's shown me first before my head has.
And so it changed my life
because I was able to repair the trauma
that was going on in my system and I mean,
it took a year for me to get to a point
where I wasn't having nightmares and flashbacks
in the middle of the night.
It was brutal, like,
but so during that time, I started all of that.
So it was like that, in conjunction with healing myself,
on crutches, I was able to sit still
and work on what I needed to work on internally.
And it was so it was so eye opening to me
to realize that I was finally in alignment
with what I do best and that's working through my feeling
and through my nervous system
instead of just trying to solve it all here.
And think about it and intellectualize it.
You gotta put pictures of bananas in your locker.
Yes, exactly.
You need to get
back to that
I need to get back to that.
That's what works for you.
That is what works.
And I had been going against what worked for me for so long,
trying to intellectualize change
and create all these thought processes that like,
I listen to all these things and read all these books
and whatever and try and do everything that I was told
nothing was working for me.
Because I wasn't getting to know myself
and what worked for me and I wasn't diving into me.
I can read all the books I want,
I can do all the things I need to do,
but if I'm not choosing my body and my system,
I'm not actually healing.
And this topic I'm so passionate about.
But, so then the caveat here is then I get a concussion.
So I'm giving blood I leave the facility,
this corner this table right here,
it's like a cement table,
I'm almost six foot, I'm five, 10
just collapse Leaning Tower of Pisa straight to the side
nail my head on the side of the concrete table
hit the floor ricochets back hits it again.
staple stitches crack my skull open.
You just, I don't get it, you slipped?
No, I just fainted.
You collapsed?
But it was like a straight to the side kinda deal.
Not just like a collapse kinda deal.
It was like a boom, as hard as possible.
So luckily, I was one minute from the ER at that facility
so went over there
Why did you faint though?
I Guess I can't give blood I guess--
Oh, that's right, you were given blood,
okay that makes sense.
I can't do that, I guess.
So which is a bummer, 'cause I was really excited
Anyway.
So basically, what I gathered from this,
the universe is like, okay,
you're starting to pay attention, but like,
we need to go a little bit deeper,
so I'm gonna literally knock you out.
Yes, and that moment, really did,
it woke me up in a very harsh way.
So I hit my head and I've never understood a brain trauma
until, I don't understand what happens with a brain trauma,
nobody does until you go through it.
You can see people with TBI,
you can see them go through concussion,
football players like people
and how like glossed over they are
how you can have a conversation with them.
they appear quote/unquote, stupid or slow.
That is real.
I couldn't string a sentence together.
Oh Well
I couldn't
have a conversation.
If you and I were sitting
right here.
When was this?
I couldn't last for five minutes
I would have gotten out and left.
I had no idea about this.
Right Christmas.
Wow.
18 sorry, at Christmas.
So like, I'm talking all this happened within.
Right, this is not too long ago.
Two months, yeah no.
So that took me until like July to heal.
Like a whole year is about a year
this is about and a half ago that I felt healed,
for the most part.
And so that was like a whole thing
where I was really working through what this TBI was like,
I couldn't associate with things,
I couldn't really understand what was going on.
And then when I started to heal,
I started to see things differently.
I was like, holy shit, like, I have a lot to unpack.
It was literally like, I got hit over the head
and it woke me up to different things that I had started
but that still needed to be dug a little bit deeper.
So we dug up another layer.
And we go a little deeper in there.
When you say we,
what does that look like working with a therapist?
Yeah, so Sarah Baldwin is the woman
I had been working with.
And so that kinda sets you back
and then you have to dive back into things
and kinda peel up what has happened for you.
'Cause actually, when you do get hit in the head,
your brain actually does,
it does rough ruffle things around
brings things up that have been buried,
which is terrifying.
So you had like weird memories that--
Weird dreams were coming back up again, weird memories.
And so that's sort of healed up there.
And then as I'm kinda getting back
into the Somatic Experiencing at that point,
which was exactly a year and a half ago now,
all the sudden, and I kid you not,
and this happened for a reason
it was the most beautiful experience
all of my trauma came back.
Everything came back to my dreams at night,
I was waking up and panics and sweats
and I don't know if you've ever experienced some of that,
like PTSD, post traumatic stress kind of feeling
where you just you feel like you're in it again.
You rebooted your operating system,
you get this head injury
and you've got, shut it down and reboot.
And those memories which were,
maybe in the some sub folder deep
on the hard drive are suddenly on the desktop,
staring at you.
Totally.
That's a good way to put it.
So, I started to finally understand.
Okay, so now that I've done the prep course,
for the healing with with Sarah,
I've done the prep course, done my prereqs
Holy shit, now I gotta like go to grad school for this
and it's gonna be really hard.
And that was really, really difficult time actually.
So difficult in a different way,
not difficult 'cause I'm going through anything particular,
not difficult 'cause it's present moment,
difficult 'cause I'm reliving everything again
in order to heal it.
'Cause I hadn't, and I had pushing it down.
And, it has been incredible,
truly incredible for me to go through this experience
because it has felt like,
I'm able to see things actually feel things,
which as painful as it can be as a feeler
to feel it again, with a different perspective
at a different chapter of your life,
you're able to understand that that's not okay.
And that that comes from somewhere,
and that pattern is there.
And then you can really, work through that,
go through that process,
unpack that and kinda move on as they come up.
And it took me a year, like I said, to not have dreams,
and nightmares and panic attacks
in the middle of the night.
I called the hotline on more than one occasion, last summer,
every other night, for months.
'Cause I thought I, your body is in that place, again,
you think you are going to die,
that's what your brain is telling you that
when you are in a traumatic state,
you don't think with a certain part of your brain at all,
you just think what do I need to do to survive right now.
And I was (indistinct)
Experiencing it as if it's happening in the moment, right?
And you'll learn all sorts of tools, to move through that,
but it would wipe me out for days.
And this is when I didn't talk to anybody.
And this is when I sort of went missing.
Like I just I hid the whole year of 2019.
Most of end of 18 and 2019, I didn't.
Everything I did was just to make sure
that people knew I was fine.
Still breathing.
So that process of, on some level,
reliving those experiences, or just,
emotionally confronting them.
I mean, that's required if you're gonna heal, right?
You've got to walk through that process.
So what was the methodology or the technique?
Was it a specific like, is it behavioral cognitive therapy?
Or what kind vein, were you exploring this in?
So it's called Somatic Experiencing SE,
Peter Levine started it,
I don't know if you've ever heard of Peter Levine.
I feel like you would love this field, by the way,
if you kinda dive into some of that SE stuff
and more of the--
Well, I had Andrew Huberman in here talking
about some of the, techniques that they use,
like, with the way that you move your (indistinct) movement
and stuff like that, and how that helps you rewire some
of your neurochemistry.
Exactly, so you're basically rewiring
your entire nervous system to think
and to feel something different
that you haven't ever felt before.
And your body is gonna wanna not do it,
you're not gonna wanna do it.
So half the time, we have to stop and start over.
But it's a lot of rapid eye movement stuff.
It's a lot of like woodsy, like ventral things
where you're like holding different parts of your body.
You recount you say the event again out loud,
and she like take notes on what parts
of your body were tensing during that process,
so that you can then realize what parts
of your body are holding on to that trauma,
and then you do work on like releasing that area,
and letting that go, because that's real.
I mean, it's stored in specific parts of our body,
mine are hips and feet, and like lower extremities.
So that's a big part of it.
Also, just essentially, I did a lot of actual active work.
So when I would go in with Sarah,
I would stay on the opposite side of the room,
she would stay on the opposite side of the room,
I would walk a little bit closer,
and she would do certain things to like,
come toward me or act a certain way.
And whatever happened, I would have to stop and explain
what that what showed up for me in that moment,
or like what happened.
I mean, there's days when I would just be like,
just sobbing my eyes out, but the whole point of this
is to let your system get rid of it.
So that you can then create space for it to rewire.
So you have to start by like, sweeping, getting rid of it,
bringing it up, letting it out, and then rewiring it.
And so now I'm like, I see her once a month.
It's so we've really weaned down but rewiring ,
At your peak, how often were you having these sessions?
Three days a week.
I was like, Well, I'm either gonna pay for it now
or pay for it later.
So I'm sick of running.
I was sick of my own bullshit.
I was sick of getting injured.
I was sick of make seeing all these symptoms pop up,
when really the issue was that I hadn't chosen
to heal myself, I had chosen to run.
I had chosen to continue to follow the same pattern
I did since I was a little girl.
And it's just, where can I run?
What can I do to just not be seen
and just make everybody happy and do all these things.
No, I need to choose myself for the first time
in a really long time, and I can't make excuses anymore.
I can't just be like, this happened to me.
It's like, no,
it's not working for me anyway.
It's super powerful.
And I love how, basically,
your life directed you towards this
by stripping you down, this was your divine moment,
like you were being compelled to confront this,
one way or the other.
And had you continue to be in denial
or refuse to engage with this,
some kind of therapeutic process,
your life was gonna continue to decline,
like your body was gonna continue to break down,
it just was a matter of how much pain
are you willing to sit with,
before you're actually gonna engage with this
and like grapple with these issues.
And here's the thing as women, as men, as well,
you pass on everything that you have not healed,
your system, and your cells actually hold trauma,
and they will actually continue to carry that on.
I don't wanna have children and pass that on to them.
I don't wanna be harboring resentment, and anger,
and, (indistinct) and pass it on to the next generation.
I don't wanna do that.
So I sort of view my purpose in life
as being able to heal so the next generations
can continue to heal,
regardless of if I have my own children or not
like that's my whole mission
is how can you create space for people to know
that they're able to be whatever they can be
if they can really work on healing
their mind and their body together.
It's possible.
It's just weird for people to understand at first it's not.
It's nuanced.
Well, it gives the work that you do
so much more resonance now, like with Rise Athletes,
and these young athletes that that you
and Rebecca are mentoring,
now that you've, undergone this experience, like,
there's so much more depth to what you can convey,
in these relationships.
And everything has started to make sense.
it's all been the same thing.
It's just shown up in all of these different ways
and different places, which I think if we look at our lives,
and we see a thread tied through them,
it's usually that thread is one thing
that everything keeps mirroring whatever it is,
in one way or in one direction or another,.
So for mine, it was this people pleasing thing
that needed to be fixed.
But then as it started to heal, it's this mind body thing
where, okay, your whole life has been surrounded
about being a feeler, so now let's use that
to your advantage, instead of using it as
you can only please people,
let's use it as a way to be in this world
as a way to change and make change.
What a relief.
And it finally all made sense.
I was like, I'm not weird, I'm not weird,
it's just who I am and that's okay
and I don't need to apologize for it anymore.
And what a gift that your body broke down,
or that you, had the traumas that you had,
so that you were given the opportunity to confront this.
Because short of that you can live your whole life,
kind of, babysitting these character defects
on the back burner, but nothing severe enough
ever happens that compels you to look at it,
to the deep extent to which you have.
So ultimately, you become the stronger, better person
because of your pain.
Yeah, and I've had some people ask me things like,
well, what if nothing's really happened to me
to where it's like, allowed me to see certain things,
it's like, I know they're there,
but nothing's really happened
to push me into that place that's like,
really bad to where I need to figure this out?
And it's a great question, and I don't necessarily know
that it has to be that way.
I think, what we--
Makes it easier,
it makes it way easier.
The thing, people ask me that question,
I'm like, I don't know what to tell you
because like, I just was in so much pain
I didn't feel like I had any other choice.
That choice is available to all of us at any moment,
it's just harder to make that choice
when you're not suffering.
'Cause who wants to do that kinda work?
Suffering does lead you--
if you feel like
you don't need to, it's like, I got shit to do.
You'll continue to.
And so I guess the only thing that I could really think
to say to someone in that position is like,
maybe you're just trying to think about it too much
and you really have to see what your body is telling you.
Because our bodies are actually giving us
so much information that we completely ignore.
And you're an expert at this.
Well, but athletes of all people
are so much more integrated in that regard,
like they've been trained to pay attention to their body
and the signals that their body is giving them.
So to the extent that you are still refusing
to pay attention to that, I think, is powerful.
But the greater point being that most people
aren't as connected to their bodies
in the way that athletes are.
So when their bodies are sending them those signals,
those signals are muted, or unhearable
because they're, clouded underneath,
layers of whatever else is going on with that person
whether they're just disconnected from that signal.
And I guess the question is, how do you teach somebody
that's disconnected from their body,
how to become connected to their body?
There's a ton of modalities,
but I think the real truth to that question
is getting to know them, and what actually
what their learning style is,
so that you can like place one of those to it.
'Cause I think there's different places everybody can start.
Some people start meditation,
some people start by changing diets,
some people start by movement,
so it's--
Some people need
spreadsheets and other people need pictures of bananas.
Yes, exactly.
There's so many ways to do this.
No, one way.
But yeah, I think that,
that's something I'm sort of exploring, now,
so a lot of people ask me that.
Well, I'm not in tune with my body so how am I supposed
to feel this somatic experience or whatever
if I don't even like, I don't feel anything?
How has the last two years changed
how you how you mentor these young athletes?
I love that question.
I think we've incorporated a lot more visualization
and imagery, work and breath work
into our program, which is huge.
Truth be told Rebecca, and I only work with two now, each
because of we have like 35 mentors.
So we sort of have to run the business side of it
instead of just mentoring.
But my specific athletes,
it's changed and that we have conversations
about what's showing up in their body.
And they're able to, every time they do it,
they get better and better.
At first, it's like, I don't know, I'm sore.
I don't know, my right shoulder is kind of sore
from 700 butterfly did yesterday.
And now it's more I was really short of breath yesterday,
'cause I was super stressed,
because I had a fight with my boyfriend
and I noticed they stopped breathing.
So it's like cool cue.
And we work on that.
And then they take that and they apply it
to their competition and to school.
It's, against the thing that runs across,
like, how can that work in multiple environments.
But it has increased awareness,
it's increase awareness for all of our mentors,
the mind body aspect in general.
Knowing that working on an athlete's mind, isn't it,
you have to really work on what they feel in their body,
what's showing up, and how to speak to their body
in a way that they can not only become more aware of it
and know what it needs, but in a way
that they can create worth through their actual being
so that it is aligned with their mind.
And they find that happening together
and things start to click, it's like,
oh, I feel less tense,
or I felt really relaxed going into that race.
What did that feel like?
Oh, my shoulders were down and I felt like I could breathe.
And yeah, I felt, so they're recognizing
what's happening in their system.
Which, if we're gonna change generations in sport,
you can't just tell them to think about things.
Sure you can but in my personal opinion, and experience,
I've never seen an athlete,
even if they love spreadsheets,
and love splits and times, like my brother
not be able to tune into their body,
in a time when they need to and understand
what's going on what it's telling them
what information that's giving them.
And to be able to do that under pressure,
or in a high stress environment
where your thinking brain isn't gonna cut it.
Yeah, you have to.
Yeah, because your body is gonna tell you first
what's going on always.
And that's the crazy thing is if we listen close enough,
and if we put in the reps, everything is reps,
reps, reps, reps, you just gotta keep putting in the reps
before you realize it.
But if you listen close enough, you're like,
I'm super jittery, like before this race,
my stomach hurts, my rib hurts,
all these things that will give you information.
Well, why do those things hurt?
What are you holding on to?
A lot of swimmers stomach hurt.
A lot of performers always claim,
they'll throw up before races, their stomach hurt,
those things are telling you something,
it's information, it's not bad
it's just information.
It's difficult to figure out what's meaningful
out of that too.
Because as you know, you're used to beating your body up
for so long during training
and then you go into this taper phase,
and then you're just hyper aware
of every little niggle in your body
and you're like, there's something wrong
because my toe hurts or something,
and you gotta just be like, no,
you're just nervous, right?
There's nothing wrong with you.
You're just hyper aware you're being hyper vigilant
because you've put so much time into preparing
for the very specific moment.
And everything in your in your world
in your experience is super heightened.
So true 'cause the amount of times I was told,
don't pay attention on how you feel.
Or don't worry about it if you hurt
or don't think about it,
don't think about how you feel.
And it was so foreign to me.
I was like, What do you mean?
That's all I do is I feel I don't understand like,
how am I not supposed to think about how I feel?
But I you nailed it with that
is it you become so hyper aware
that how can you reframe whatever it is
that you're feeling in your system as an okay thing,
as something that's just giving you information,
accepting it, the practice of acceptance,
if you're at a race or whatever,
and your right knee hurts,
but you're behind the blocks.
Well, not a lot you can do now.
So reps of doing that in practice,
reps of doing that with a sports site consultant,
reps of doing that with your coach, like,
what is it that means?
How can I reframe whatever it is in that moment,
through injury or through pain
that I can then use toward whatever I need to get done,
and then address it after if it's something serious,
when it comes like injury and whatnot.
But yeah, that whole field of injury psychology
is really cool.
You should pick (indistinct) brain on that sometime.
Yeah, I've never spoken about that specifically with--
It's a whole deal.
It's for sure, it's really interesting.
Like when I was in grad school,
Do you guys hang out?
We used to work out together.
And then he started a different gym routine.
He came to my gym.
We were buddies.
I see him, at source cafe every now and then.
He is the best, he doesn't like neighbors down there.
Yeah, he's great, I loved Durey.
We've always just had like a great rapport.
But yeah, that field is really cool.
Well, I wanna talk about your relationship to sport now
because if you scroll through your Instagram,
you're getting after it, whether it's CrossFit,
or like swimming in the ocean, like,
you still have this profound love for movement
and fitness, but what's interesting
is that it's completely outside
of any competitive context, right?
Like, I almost feel like, like,
it was a blessing that you didn't go and do Otillo.
Because you're not supposed to be,
your relationship to sport isn't supposed
to be about competition, even if you could have done that,
from a healthy perspective of not really caring,
like about how well you did
and just enjoying the experience.
I think there's something beautiful and instructive
about how you've completely reframed your relationship
to sport so that it has nothing to do with any metric.
Other than like, joy.
Exactly.
So it's interesting, I started to wanna be a student
of different things.
I'm very curious.
I wanted to try different things
because after I broke my heels,
I couldn't really do endurance things like run and whatnot.
Like I used to me, that was what I needed to get done
when I retired, right, run, run, run, run, run
and keep running.
And I love running.
But I was like, let's see what's possible.
Let's see what's possible with your body.
And things great as long as you're running towards
something and not away.
Away yes.
I'm just yes.
I'm so obsessed with running.
Running awesome for running away from stuff.
Yeah, running's great once you're running away oh yeah.
It was fast as hell yeah.
So I started getting curious.
And I started thinking, Okay, Caroline,
you did the same thing for ever.
Let's see what's possible.
And let's test the boundaries a little bit
and see what your body can handle what it can't,
learn a little bit more about what your adrenals
and kidneys can handle learn a bit
about what they can't.
So I started taking courses at the gym,
I took strength 101 course I took a strongman course
I took a weightlifting course.
I start swimming in the ocean.
What else have I done?
I think that's pretty much it mainly strengthening edition.
But those three courses were eight to 10 weeks long each.
So over a span of two years I took these courses.
What's that CrossFit gym and Venice.
(indistinct) that's right.
So they actually have a two to three gyms,
one in Venice, one in Hermosa and one in Hollywood.
And so I was at the Hermosa one.
And I loved it, because all of a sudden,
I entered back into like, eight year old Caroline.
And it was like, everything's new.
I can do whatever.
I can learn things.
I don't have to be like a veteran at this and like,
I can just start over again with everything
and feel new and learn.
And I became so obsessed with learning.
I loved it so much that I felt like a little kid again
a student and throughout I remember just being
so sad week at graduation day of these courses
'cause I was just just now getting started off
I get this, this is a new skill.
I love learning new skills and I love
being able to see what my body can handle.
And so throughout this process,
I have quickly learned that strength,
strict strength is not my jam.
My body is not built to just like back or left.
Very traditional weightlifting, I mean.
Yeah, I love it, I need it.
But it's not like what I'm very good at.
loved learning it though,
could really pick and balances out.
But I took a strongman course, which I loved.
And it's exactly like swimming movements.
So it's like full body like stones
and like (indistinct).
Around and stuff.
Yes, like you're doing like caveman stuff.
And I was just in love, like flipping tires.
I was just in love with it.
I felt like very prime,
it was a very primal feeling kind of thing.
And everything is like a short circuit.
And you really only train it twice a week,
it's all you need, I love that.
That was my favorite.
And I could do that (indistinct)
That's little different from four workouts a day.
Yes, yes.
And so about around that time,
this was the second course I took around
that time I started to realize, okay, Caroline,
remember when you couldn't train,
more than four times a week at Florida
once you got down to the wire
and understood what you needed.
Same thing with this,
don't overthink the fact that you only need
to train two times a week here, train two times a week,
do the other days just a longer walk
something smooth some yoga,
and I was in the best shape of my life.
My body loved it, and all of a sudden it was like,
less is more, feel yourself into this.
You don't need to overtrain your adrenals
don't need to go to town with all of this 20 hours a day
kind of stuff.
You gotta unravel all that programming around,
the kind of training you were doing in college.
And that's what these courses served a purpose for,
is it retired taught me again, how to be an athlete.
And I didn't have to just be one type of athlete.
I could be multiple different versions of myself
and learn what I needed.
And it was beautiful, especially if it's gonna
change every year, I'm 34 I'm not 24 it's gonna change.
So then I took a weightlifting course,
which was like snatches and power cleans
and I really enjoyed that.
That did tax my nervous system a little more for me.
So out of out of learning these things,
I really did settle on, like,
a couple days a week of strength training
is perfect for me, the other day is really (indistinct).
Jump in the ocean.
Yes,
like so on Tuesday, Thursday, Saturday is now I walk.
And I'm just I mean, I'm like expert power Walker
in South Bay, just doo doo.
And I love it Rich, like I am listening to podcasts
and music and before I know it, I've walked
five and a half miles just walking, just go for it.
Come back, and I feel great.
And that's same as swimming, swimming 1500
you get out of the ocean and you're fine.
(indistinct) 1500
That's actually a lot,
But you look crazy strong and super fit and happy.
And clearly you're on the other side of this whole process.
Like with some clarity and a lightness to you.
Yeah, thanks.
I think I have a little ways to go on finding.
I don't know, finding my voice is the right word.
But I'm still learning that it's okay to have opinions.
So learning it's okay to speak my mind.
I know I still learning it.
People pleasing thing is tough man.
I suffer from that tremendously.
It's not easy.
It's it's hard to I think with social media stuff,
'cause I feel like who I am as a person
can't be portrayed in a square.
So it's like--
How about a rectangle?
Yeah, I'm like, what other app can I join
that feels like me,
I don't know.
It's just it's a funny world.
But I'm still waiting for myself to believe in myself
a little more with things I have to say.
And things that I I can only hope that storytelling
and sharing experiences will allow other people
to feel empowered to do the same.
'Cause I think we connect through experiences
and through being able to share our lives with people.
So I love what you're doing with Prophets Walk Among Us,
like, that's exactly it.
That's exactly what it is that life is about
is everybody has a story to tell,
and how else are we going to
get to understand ourselves and others?
It's the only way forward.
And I think that's why I'm such a strong believer
in conversations like this,
because to the extent that your life experiences
is vastly different from somebody who's listening,
there is a shared humanity and my hope
and my belief is that the person who needs
to connect with what you have to say
is gonna connect with it,
and it's only by giving a person like yourself
enough bandwidth to share themselves openly
over time that you allow that process to occur.
Yeah, it takes a minute to get there too.
And no shame if people aren't ready
to share their stories and their lives,
I certainly wasn't.
For however many years.
If I was to plop you down onto the pool deck
of Olympic trials, like right now, like,
and you had to go see all these coaches
and all these old friends,
what does that bring up for you, right now?
In a weird way, it's the first word that came to mind
was peace, like, I just feel okay with it.
like, I feel like it would maybe not peace,
maybe indifferent.
Like, of course, you have the,
what does this person think of me based on the, the,
the situation two years ago, or, based on whatever,
what is this, but at the same time,
kinda like--
That's their business,
not mine.
So I'm just sort of indifferent,
I think I, I see myself as a human more
than a swimmer now than than I used to,
I used to only be able to identify
with my worth in life with that,
and that's why it was so confusing.
Because my worth was identified as something
that I was proud of,
but that I was also like, that's, that's it.
That's not me, I don't wanna be associated
with that all the time, like they're--
I think the confusing and somewhat pernicious
aspect of that is that it's not like your parents,
or the coaches, or anybody is saying,
you're only valuable to me,
to the extent that you perform.
It's not like that, totally, it's,
it's a more ephemeral systemic thing where,
maybe it's not even an expectation,
but it's just an environment
in which you're reared to believe
that you're more valuable if you perform at a higher level.
You start to Intuit that you imbue that and then
that becomes like this, seed of destruction later.
Yes, and just on that note,
I always want to say that
you can have your feelings about sport
and your experiences, and also be so passionate
about what you're doing to create change,
and to create something better for the world.
It's like anybody that goes through something,
and then they become an activist in that thing,
so that they can create change.
But it doesn't mean that they're still angry at that.
And I think I'm to the point now,
where I'm not angry at it anymore.
It's like, I'm just in a space of like, okay,
the anger has subsided, like, that was strong,
but now it's just like, okay, like,
let's do something about this.
That feels honest to me, and I think,
ultimately, with your continued,
commitment to growth, that ultimately,
you could land on that pool deck and just be excited,
and joyful and looking forward to seeing these people
as opposed to indifferent.
And I definitely wanna get to the point
where it's like, hell yeah.
And I would have met, evolution is not,
it's not linear it's also not instant.
I think a lot of people go through,
that path of, well, is this happening now, or never?
Or do I give up?
Or do I keep going?
And the answers keep going.
Yeah, you just keep going.
You can't gauge the process when you're in it anyway?
100% not, you can't even see it.
And I don't think that any human that sits in
this chair that talks to you has anything figured out.
Nobody has anything figured out.
We're all still learning.
And I say that with utmost love for everybody.
I learned so much from people that,
speak on your podcast that speak on multiple
and I'm sitting here thinking,
how vulnerable it is to hear from people
that are still growing, how cool is it that we can learn
from people that are still growing and still learning
and still sharing in five years,
they're gonna have something totally different to say.
I think it's more powerful that way.
When somebody is delivering some message
from the perspective of I've I have it all figured out
and let me tell you, here's how you do it.
I immediately tune out.
Yeah, I wanna hear, the honest,
vulnerable truth of somebody who's made progress
but is struggling and is sharing
their experience from the heart.
Like that's what I'm able to connect with.
Yeah, we're all sharing what we're still processing.
It's just a matter of if we're aware of it or not,
like we're all sharing things we're still working through.
So maybe a good way to end it is
to share a little bit or impart a little bit
of wisdom or experience to the younger athlete
who's tuning in, who perhaps is feeling like their worth
is being measured by the extent to which
they're able to perform or who feels like they're not able
to be themselves completely
in whatever lane they've chosen right now,
and is trying to figure out how
to have a healthier relationship to,
maybe it's sport, but maybe it's some other thing
that they're involved in.
Well, there's two things.
One is that you can be feeling,
it's okay to feel that way.
Your feelings are valid.
I think that is very important for a young athlete to feel,
your feelings are valid, they're not right or wrong.
There's they're not measured.
But learning how to use them constructively.
Whether it's through sharing
or understanding it communicating,
and being able to use those and move forward
with whatever that is the key.
So I think we get wrapped up in not saying anything,
'cause we're afraid upset somebody.
But if there's somebody that you can share
how you feel with and that feels like a safe space for you,
feel safe to validate your feelings,
say it's okay, you feel that way,
let's get a little more information about that.
What is it that's really showing up there
and really understanding that the human's heart first.
They're gonna be able to perform better,
they're gonna be able to take that
and use whatever that is
and turn it into something constructive.
Because I think we we get stuck in our feelings,
and we get stuck just thinking they don't matter,
brushing them away, pushing them away, really,
there's so much power in it,
there's so much information to be had in that,
that's beautiful, regardless of if they're positive
or negative, you can take that remold it and turn it
into an amazing performance,
grade on a test relationship with somebody
with your family members, extra curricular,
whatever it is that that person's wanting to do.
So that's something I like to say,
'cause I think we're shameful of our feelings.
We're shameful of what that means.
There's nothing wrong with that.
It's just information.
And I wish I would have known that.
I wish I would have been okay,
knowing that however I felt was okay.
And then it wasn't there anything wrong with it,
it was just information.
Yeah, that's beautiful.
I think it's super important.
I feel like, at least in the context of sport,
there has been a lot of progress and movement
in the right direction
in terms of better understanding that aspect of it.
I mean, I'm two generations older than you,
but when I see, the way that young athletes
are being coached and mentored now,
compared to what it was like, when I was a kid,
I mean, that was long time ago.
But, of course, much more,
there's much more to be gleaned and learned.
Totally mental health is at the forefront right now.
People are caring about how people feel.
And I know this is an important thing to note
is that you can be struggling, and also be okay
with your performances.
You can admit that you're having a hard time
and also you'll, you'll still be okay,
you can still be and do great things.
I think there's a misunderstanding there
that if I, again, back to that,
if I share that I'm depressed
or having a hard time or going through something,
then that means
It's gonna--
Be well.
Impinge on your performance, right?
I mean, that's the whole message
of the weight of gold, right?
It's like kind of a call to action
to embrace that aspect of what it means to be vulnerable
and to have the courage to raise your hand and ask for help.
The shrouding of it, the hiding of it,
because you're supposed to be this bulletproof individual
is not in service to anybody, and certainly not yourself.
And it's not complaining, it's owning,
it's self ownership.
I think there's a difference between complaining
I have some athletes say, well, I wanna complain.
It's if we can shift it to itself ownership,
then we can take that and use it.
Just because you're having a hard time
have asked for help, et cetera
it doesn't mean you're all the sudden gonna perform poorly.
It doesn't mean that you're not focusing
on your swimming or your baseball or whatever,
it means that you're doing something for your mental health,
which will then help that so it's a perspective shift.
It does require some level of mind-body integration,
though because you have to know when you
are copping out like am I just am I just one thing out,
or am I really in jeopardy where I need some help?
There is a difference.
And if you don't have that kind of intuition,
then you might be just, indulging in your laziness,
instead of really being imperil.
But that's where great coaches and mentors come in.
Because if somebody is vulnerable enough
to share whatever it is, then they can catch that,
and be able to change that and turn that into something.
Otherwise, they will just sit in their shit,
so to speak, and, let it go to shit.
And well whatever, I'm just copping out.
So if they can articulate that,
communicate that information to whomever, coach mentor.
And this is where coaches and mentors can hear that,
taking that information and being able to help somebody,
being able to identify it without shame,
and turn it into something better.
Call them out on what it is, in a nice way,
in a beautiful way, like, hey you're tough,
let's make something out of this,
we're not gonna let this happen to you here.
That's where things can shift for the positive.
'Cause you're changing the behavior
through let's act on this.
Let's move through this, let's not tell you what's wrong,
and just make you sit in it longer.
Let's, make some change here,
let's do something and that's on you.
You're the one athlete, you're the one that needs
to make the change I'm here to guide you.
Yeah, well, I think that responsibility,
like we're kind of talking about it
from the perspective of the athlete,
what their responsibility is,
but that responsibility also rests on the coach
to create an environment that's conducive
and safe for that person to do that.
And I think that this is applicable outside of sport
in the workplace, like a boss, employee relationship,
or how management is structured so
that the work staff feels they can, raise certain issues,
and the manager is creating an environment
that's conducive to that.
I think, ultimately leads to a much more
effective healthy place to work
or environment to excel as an athlete.
Absolutely, and that is one of the most important things
that I think any organization can hold, coaches, teams,
USA Swimming, is that if the standard is held there,
and if people are all believing
in whatever leadership there is, and the leaders are able
to develop these people, athletes, employees,
whatever it is into a space of vulnerability, openness,
and action on what it is that we're doing,
not just talking about it and sitting around,
it's like actually acting on it,
whether that action is let's sit with this for a minute.
Or that action is let's take action
and do something right now.
Both of those things are beautiful.
That's how things develop.
And yeah, those are my greatest learnings from Mike De Boer,
is he was just very much either like, okay, let's,
now that we have that information,
let's either go this way and act on it immediately.
Or I'm gonna let you sit with that for a second.
I'm here right here next to you,
but I'm gonna let you sit with that in a second.
And like, knowing that I was like, held in that space,
I think, reflecting back that makes all the difference,
'cause either ways in action
you're giving you're empowering them either way.
I gotta figure it out on their own either way,
but it's the person that's
gonna hold steady and sturdy there
that's holding a leadership standard.
That you believe in that.
Last thing.
Were there any books that stand out
that you've read through this process of trying to,
manage everything that you've showed a couple years
that you found to be helpful?
Yeah, well, I love yours, by the way
that I just got, wish I got it a long time ago.
It's gonna help anybody with their people pleasing.
No, it does but it also does help you feel not alone.
So that's huge.
The, my favorite books are very abstract.
So I like "Eastern Body Western Mind,"
if you've read that book.
"The Body Keeps Score."
Huge for me.
I'm actually reading "Becoming Supernatural" right now,
which I really love.
"Loyalty To Your Soul."
I read like a lot of mind body style books
to where you're integrating
like energy centers with mindset work.
So it's an abstract way of thinking.
I could name all my books and sports likes
in grad school, but those are just sports likes.
I'm thinking more in the context of somebody
who's dealing with these kind of particular emotional things
that you've been dealing with.
And I didn't read a book for
however many years during--
I saw your latest Instagram post about that.
I didn't read one single book.
I started reading like when I broke my heel,
I start reading again.
I start doing everything
that I hadn't done again, to try.
But those are the books I gravitated toward.
I gravitated toward books that felt like
intuitively they were calling me to they were
I was drawn to them 'cause they were about the things
that I felt unseen with that I that I needed
to understand better about myself,
which was that connection between the mind and the body
in a way that wasn't just psychology and sports psych,
then where there was like a very spiritual sense
that I could understand a little bit better about myself.
But there are several others in there
that I really enjoyed throughout that time.
I'm probably blanking on a lot of them.
But--
Well you can email me
a list or whatever, we'll put them up in the show notes.
I'll go through my little shelf.
Yeah, got a lot of good ones.
Burclke's reading List from the mind is somebody
who didn't read books for six years.
Yeah, it's like just sketchbooks and like, yeah.
Pictures of bananas.
Cool.
So what's left?
Like, what's the what's the thing
that's tripping you up now?
Or like the hurdle that you're trying to overcome?
I think the last the last part of what
I was just talking about my voice and finding
what it is that I feel okay to talk about.
It's really difficult, like,
I'm very comfortable with you,
I can talk with you about these things.
But I feel like something that I'm really working
on and getting over is feeling judged
for how do you share your story?
And what it is that I'm, that I stand by,
without sounding like this complaining victim or something.
And I would really like to get to the bottom of that.
'Cause it feels like, I get stuck in that space
of so much to say, and I have so much I believe in
that I articulating it still, I don't know,
I wanna feel confident in that,
that it's just sharing,
and not making anybody feel sorry for me or anything.
I think, it's about intention.
What is your intention?
What's your motivation?
What's behind the desire to write whatever it is
you you're gonna write or say,
whatever it is, you're gonna say?
If it's coming from a whiny place, then,
it's gonna come off as complaining.
But if it's coming from a desire to share
and service to other people
who might be experiencing those emotions,
then it has a different tenor to it.
I love connection.
I can connect with people.
That's my number one intention.
I just I love connection.
It's everything to me.
So whenever I hear people experienced something similar
or go through something and approach me
about it or ask questions.
It feels like we're human together.
I feel like we can be constructive in that conversation
and not feel like it's just a problem.
Well, you must get that with Rise, though.
All these relationships with these?
Yeah, I definitely do.
And I really enjoy that.
And I've been sketching more and getting back
to my (indistinct) roots a little bit.
Which I love it.
I just I started drawing just fashion sketches.
And then I was just like, shoot,
I'm just gonna draw the body
and that actually started helping me heal my body.
I started sketching during my concussion, by the way,
'cause I couldn't formulate words.
But that was huge.
So that was really helpful for me in order
to connect with people 'cause I met a whole new community
of people in the art world.
And that felt really cool to explain and share what it is
that I'm doing through I'm healing my body through sketching
I'm healing my, my body and my mind
through drawing the body through becoming one with my body
again, that I struggled with for so long.
So that was really cool.
And that was a whole new world
that opened up my eyes to connection
and that there's a lot of a lot of worlds out there.
Yeah, a lot of people out there.
There's a lot of stuff out there that
I can open my eyes to finally,
well as somebody 20 years as a senior,
I can tell you that there's plenty more out there
for you to learn more, and I can't wait to see
where you end up directing your energy.
Oh, thanks, I'm excited for it.
I'll probably call you up for some advice .
Anytime.
That was super inspiring.
Thank you.
And I think it's I think it's gonna be really helpful
to a lot of people so I appreciate it.
I adore you.
I want only good things for you.
And I hope that you consider me a friend and a resource.
I for sure do, thank you so much.
Cool, so if you wanna connect with Caroline,
you can find her on Instagram Carol Burckle there.
If you're an athlete in search of mentorship,
you should check out Rise Athletes rise.athletes.com
Rise dash athlete, yeah.
Rise dash athletes.com.
Which I should have said earlier is the company
that you and Rebecca Soni founded
to be the Kind of mentor to young athletes
that you wish you guys had had when you were younger.
I had Rebecca on very early on in the podcast,
and she shares a lot about that.
So you can check out that episode as well.
And your website, Carolineburckle.com.
Where you can buy art prints.
(indistinct)
I'm selling originals.
And at some point, perhaps.
(indistinct)
I'm so down.
Do you know, Garrett Weber Gail just did it
No way.
And Austin
he does the other day.
He was all fired up, he loved it.
He's great.
He has such good energy.
He's hysterical and he's doing the same mission.
he went through the same struggles.
He's gone through a trying
to figure out what his thing is.
I always enjoyed him.
We got along great, he's a jokester.
Cool.
All right, we'll come back and talk to me again sometime.
I will, I'm down
Peace, plants.